hello everybody oh my mic I need that
hello
everybody spooky spooky Tidings to you
my
[Music]
friends is that Gabe it's not Friday oh
wait no that's a uh werewolf I believe
you sending a wolf that's right welcome
everybody it is a Street podcast we are
here it's Monday October 30th and as you
can
tell it's Halloween tomorrow's
[Music]
Halloween but uh today is the Halloween
special we have so much fun planned
people kept asking what are you guys
going to do the ghost hunt this year
we're taking the year off the ghost
hunting and here's why why I know that
it's a fan favorite and I personally
love doing it but everywh we do it every
year we do that [__] nobody watches
it you know what I mean like that's
probably our highest production effort
video of the Year and no goddamn nobody
ever watches it nobody cares true Queen
so we're going to mix it up this year
um also I'm really sad to say that my
the strongest flashlight in the world
was stolen or something one of you
miss excuse me yeah no like that thing I
didn't know that that was one of my
favorite purchases that was your
favorite toy was like a th000 bucks
stealing it it's just missing just
missing I think it went uh Missing at
the live show um that was the last time
anybody remembers seeing it so that's
why I'm saying one of you one of you
people in the audience you have it and
you know who you are no it was probably
one of the crew yeah an employee yeah
yeah I mean I know one guy here really
loves lights a did you steal my [__]
listen if if I'm I'm stealing something
it's definitely one of your old play
buttons If those go missing you know
it's me bro take it dude please take it
I'm always like let's auction off the
play buttons let's do something and and
ab's always like no are sacred what are
you
doing yeah so um let's go ahead and uh
go around and talk about all of our
wonderful uh outfits today of course I
am
uh
[Music]
what happened I didn't like
it Ethan Slater is that where your uh oh
yeah SL his name is his name is Ethan
Slater it is so I was saying I'm
Broadway
SpongeBob combined with this iconic
8-year-old's face makeup of SpongeBob
but what's interesting is
that Ethan Slater the guy who I'm
dressed
as face is actually quite a bit scarier
than uh how dare you God how dare you
say that what was he arrested for oh is
that not a mug
shot
that's I think I think it's very
handsome because it's my date today
because I we love each other we're so in
love I don't care about my wife or my
newborn child I just want some of that
strange
Ariana ass slay okay
beautiful no but he did he did leave his
newborn and wife so we like to make fun
of him for that don't we folks [__]
my wife's MTH so that's us we're
SpongeBob and Ariana
yes and as you can see did the iconic um
booody and
like
whoa
who I'm SpongeBob this is crazy hey
everybody I'm
SpongeBob does this look right this
is don't show the back why does it look
so weird I don't know so there's only
like one belt loop here and two really
far out here so I was like do they both
go here or do they go here Square
Pants square ass pants I know so that's
what we're doing that's who we are let's
go ahead let's go around love who are
you uh what the
[__] excuse and I got my [__]
your [__] Hong with right
what what I don't understand who are you
gamb punch punch punch punch punch you
stream on punch stream on punch what
does that mean streaming service
gambling g g g Punch Yeah I okay I don't
I'm not quite sure who he is I'm still
not sure what he's saying what
car carrot
car you know I can't understand what
he's saying but we'll figure it out
shout out to punch I guess can we look
closely at his
[Applause]
watch fa ni more than thank you love
whoever you are can't understand uh Dan
who are
you I am dressed up as Rich Lux today y
we love girl we love you girl Dan is the
queen Dan is the queen Dan is the queen
you can't do nothing wrong Dan is the
queen and why and are you going to talk
like rich I'm not going to talk like
Rich because the we got off on a bad
start on a relationship because he
thought that I was mocking well it
wasn't his voice but some somebody
thought it I was uh being insulting to
somebody's voice uh which was
but just to avoid any controversy today
I'll be speaking in my normal speak here
but I am the queen I am the queen I can
do nothing wrong you can't do nothing
wrong we love Dan we love Dan Dan is the
queen very good I'm excited your Rich
Lux I thought that was such a great idea
to honor a great Community member Rich
Lu you know and we have the chair we
didn't get this for for this but he he
sits in the chair and his video is very
similar to this one it's like maybe is
the same one yeah like I'm right now I
knew that it feel like the same one it's
like almost the same let me find a
picture of him I knew that chair would
come back and
use what did we buy it for I swear to
God I still think those were like
delivered to the wrong address or
something because no one like what they
were for we bought them no I know but we
I knew they looked crazy what did we get
them for something the 5% sketch no we
used it for that we used it for that it
was for something else that
I can't remember it must it was like a
Frenemies something but I think it was
post Frenemies maybe I don't know maybe
you just saw them and thought they were
funny and said get them that's possible
so um Dan is the
queen uh moving on thank you did you
want to show the chair or we we we're
good uh I can't find a good picture the
only one that I found looks super
different it's like a pink chair but I
know I've seen him sitting in
one okay oh that one's that one's fire
yeah he's got like the heart top right
he is D Rich Lux is the queen Dan he
just called him Dan so thank you uh rich
nice to see you in studio here
today up next we have uh oh my God our
alternate clickbait title which we
decided is Colleen Ballinger in the
studio for a live interview no
way hey guys hey guys hi guys it's not
Colleen it's her alter ego I think that
this is the video that would have went
over well I think her and her are
sisters apologies ukes and what it did
go hand inh handed [__] me right not not
what I appreciate so you're
saying Miranda plus ukulele would have
been forgiven I say ukulele plus Miranda
would have made more sense to my
eyes not a good I think Colleen should
have existed did out of that fantasy you
should not have even touched that would
have been pretty crazy response to yeah
go
Maranda character I I heard a little bit
of an impression there did you don't
hold out us Onna don't hold out us it's
me that's what I can do that's what I
can give
you okay all right that's all we get
okay um yeah no but Miranda's wearing
like a little skirt this is Miranda if
she spent the summer with me yeah yes
yes yes yes we love that
fart fart joke she denounces that wait
wait wa wait what was the fart joke
lying about again fart joke the horrible
horrible when she like disgusting thing
that she did right it aart it was aart
joke stab me repeatedly in my bony
little back in my bony little in my hot
anorexic I'm so skinny I back still
funny dud I got to tell you the Colleen
apology is going to go down as one of
the best times like looking back like
YouTube Rewind ah fortnite like it's
that good Kpop K-pop K-pop it's that
good yeah and just in the genre like
where do we go from here I feel a little
lost when it comes to the genre of
apology videos like how do we top that
well you know we we always say like uh
they used to say Dan turn of the 19th
centur that there's nothing more to
invent they're like we don't need what
are we going to do we've got it all and
the truth is that's never the case I I
at one point thought we couldn't ever
top some of the apologies we've seen and
then
Miranda came out God bless her soul or
Colleen with this ukul and you know you
just never know when those Paradigm
shifts are going to come right in terms
of YouTube apology so true you know I
mean what could be next geez I don't
know like
uh keemstar from like Dexter es murder
scene I mean apologizing from the scene
from the scene of the murder I mean that
would be pretty intense sorry about all
this
murderer gesturing to the body I did it
my
bad I did that
[__] uh but okay
Miranda okay sponge okay okay okay we
love it we love it AB uh who we love so
well AB who are you I'm is the show
relevant character Anakin
Skywalker I don't recall Anakin showing
that much
chess really I think he did did he
really hold on he was BR up he was
modest he's not a [__] like a over well
you know it's you know a lot of people
like to make Halloween costumes more
provocative right that's true actually I
was wearing it the wrong way the first
time it was a lot more open than this
really yeah here I'm going to type I'm
going to open up a phone oh no he's very
modestly dressed what I'm saying I'm
sorry I was trying to back you up that
dude won't that dude wouldn't show he
does not show any chest my dude zero
what do we call this area we learned
last
time the the arur the deage oh
the yes I mean here's
a here's Anakin you
know but I typed Luke's oh no I typed
Anakin that's why Luke no he's Anakin
he's Anakin you're Anakin Anakin well
then here you go I mean this dude is
covered up this is basically like a
fundamentalist very no but look at the
costume that's how that's how it came I
put my robe on is that better I can see
your titties if you lean
[Laughter]
over you look great though you want to
see you got the lightsaber you got the
whole thing I got the whole thing baby
stand up model it you got the whole
freak this is like such an elaborate
costume to be honest damn man it's
pretty good is the saber oh you got the
false hand too yeah let me see nice got
the robo hand I don't [__] around is the
saber a prop or does it shoot does it
have any cool abilities it was a like
one of those like nice like professional
toy lightsabers is my brothers and I
accidentally broke it a long time ago
and then I just turned into a prop very
good I do have a backup one very good
very always have a backup I'll tell you
we bought the boys these Lightsaber toys
from Disneyland and I [__] hate those
things man but the kids loved it they
loved it but man those things suck so
annoying so loud they're impossible to
turn off they hit everything it's just
so up I literally tried to drown it in
water and it was wouldn't stop it was
still making the sound so my dad on all
my toys that made sound he taped the
speaker so quiet yeah they had this one
lightsaber a few years ago where you
could customize the sound it's just a
kid's lightsaber from Target whatever
you say it repeats it and that was a
[__] nightmare cuz kids would be like
hi and then the faster you swing I hi hi
hi hi hi non God what that sounds
fun um moving over we have Lena who is
also on theme uh Lena wonderful two
Jedi I'm Moka yes you guys will have the
most four sensitive
kids definitely they will be strong yes
you are what's her name Ahsoka ahoka
ahoka that's cool are you a star war
uh are you both star war heads sort of
yeah he got me into it really what do
you mean sort of ab you no well I I like
Star Wars was the first thing we both
like kind of when I showed it to her she
was into it I was like all right let's
let's go with this cuz there's a lot of
nerdy [__] I like but the fact that she
was into it at first when I showed it to
her I kind of do a little deeper in let
me ask you this Lena was there ever
something too nerdy that you're like I
can't I can't follow you
there no I don't think so
you know what I mean but that there you
go that's that's what it is it's love I
thought Star Wars was nerdy at first but
after you were he explained it to me one
day it was like we got Taco Bell and we
were just sitting in the parking lot
eating and he was telling me a little
bit about the story and I'm like this
sounds really cool so I watched all the
movies do you remember what you were
eating oh that's so cute no I don't we
were blitzed that's all I I was 1% going
to say that you were you had to okay
there's no other explanation for that
story setting I was like now was my
[Laughter]
chance L did you paint your um shoulders
oh oh you did your whole all your skin a
little red I had to fall out yeah it
looks super
good yeah wow I thought I thought maybe
you just got like a tan or something but
a legit costume it's really even yeah
thank you I had to do the costume
Justice very good very good thanks and
where's your uh uh
lightsaber it is
oh there it is there it is
yeah
ni thank you to Lena and ab who will uh
beautiful they're going to change the
they're going to change that the balance
of the force I'm sure of
it they're going to have a big effect uh
moving over to uh she doesn't know how
to turn off sorry I'm trying to turn it
off that's the thing thing to turn off
it's so freaking there's no off button
you have to like push five times wait
yeah it's there's one button with five
different features yep it's the same one
the kids had man that something that I
can't turn off uh Ian who tell us about
yourself
Ian yeah I'm
um uh Jimmy
jigsaw because Mr BEAST's uh contests
have been getting more and more
diabolical
and horrifying um I think he's about to
snap
actually so I'm just foreshadowing it I
made my this is my custom uh Beast
blade oh no not the Mr Beast bars that's
sick oh I'm sure it's not too long until
he puts two people in a room with a
hacksaw and one make your choice would
you like to play a game you better hurry
up you better hurry up very good you're
certainly on to something and I want Den
I it the man has a t he's got a taste
for blood and I've been seeing it in his
recent videos they've been getting more
and more
morose dark there's something hidden
there right he has two people like
locked in a cage right now yeah like he
was talking about it there's like an
ongoing thing where he has these two
people locked in a [__] room together
he tweeted out I have two people locked
in a room they get $10,000 a day and
then if one of them leaves they both
lose all their money so it'll turn into
like almost like a physical violence
thing so keep them there but then the he
goes I think I've made a mistake cuz
they're never going to leave so these
two people are in like a dark room I
imagine you know eating like raviolis
out of a
can that Chef colleting rainwater yeah
yeah that's pretty crazy but imagine if
you've been in there for like 3 months
yeah and it's like at whatever 300 three
well 3 months 10,000 a day that would be
a million
yeah and so the other person's like I
can't take it I got to go you that there
might be violence at that point God I
hope so yeah You' think like so if the
other person stays if it's just a body
does that still
count you know you know that's that's a
good
question that is a good question who
right I'm sure that was in the uh the
release the guideline the the guid rules
by the way speaking of Mr Beast poor
rosanah mhm she had the bail on the
whole thing yeah yeah that's sad the
beast boys came
from the drama life not
easy I feel bad not easy you know she
was
just it's not easy people are wild but I
I knew people were going to be so mean
about it yeah you know oh you think it's
because of that because of what of like
backlash that she got oh it is 100% oh
it is okay yeah thought too they were
getting I thought she maybe got a little
phone call that's what they were saying
this morning I think it was it was it
was the amount of hate apparently
they're getting like death threats and
you know how it is death threats yeah
dude Mr [__] beast bro I told you
people just go up and give him money
people literally kissed his feet right
that shit's so crazy to
me the thing is you never know when Mr
Beast is going to bust out 10,000 for
you so people are always like Mr Beast
like a modern day Emperor like Mr Beast
yes Mr Beast please please throw us a
gold
coin I throw change for the peasants and
watch them scramble it's my favorite
daytime
activity uh thank you
Ian you're welcome thank you you're so
welcome thank you Sam we are moving on
to what are we have here Sam I am not
show relevant but I am Mad Hatter guess
kind of CU didn't Johnny du play
mad he did and that's show relevant
because because we're such big John
stands heads you can do nothing very
relevant topic on the show you know what
I just had the best idea a podcast just
about Johnny Depp called out of your
Depp
y That's a good that's good right it's
good so anyway I love your costume Sam
yeah thank you look great you want to
stand up you did the whole
you did the whole thing those lashes
show off those lashes please do you want
to stand up or
no yeah show off yeah so cool okay
okay yes she's mad Sam made the top
herself she's nice I was going to ask
that it looks legit oh that looks
beautiful it's based off of a costume
that was sold out that I really wanted
so I just recreated like the same
costume only Sam only
gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous up next we
have
Zachariah how you doing Zachariah who is
um I'm 70s rock icon Alice
Cooper sure is wow wearing my leather
pants dude very nice very nice also very
show relevant yes very uh there's a way
to connect it how do we connect Tois I
got it Ellis Cooper is friends with
Johnny Deb don't they sing together
sometimes Hollywood vampires they have a
band together and they're in a movie
together okay I'll I'll be talking about
Alice Coop
vampires wonder what happened backstage
in those shows and let's not forget our
uh resident Snow White
himself uh Cameron grants who is a who
you Frolic and there it is hey dab dab
on him no guys I'm here in the Forest in
Japan nothing could go wrong oh scarious
hanging right dead
body dab on them you know what's funny
after all this time it's still a good
costume right it's still a good costume
been a few years and like how imagine
dressing like such a [__]
[__] during your biggest controversy I
know what that's like I think I do that
every time true I'll probably say
something [__] up
today um so uh that's everybody uh we're
all here and we're all looking fantastic
love it yeah really
fantastic um besides that so today we
have a few really fun segments planned
the first one we've got here is are you
faster oh Jesus than Michael Myers the
[Music]
masked the masked demon or is he just
like a reanimated corpse what's the deal
with no he's he's human I wish he's
human he's human yeah he's human but
there's like some Supernatural aspects I
wish Lena was here she's like a huge fan
because that's her biggest fear in the
world is Michael Myers to this day like
she still has nightmares about it really
but she's cool with this we checked with
her yeah yeah no no she's
excited um so mik turn up the mic so
what we're doing here today is we have
got the biggest scariest person we could
find in fact no it is Mike Myers here
today and in fact why don't we cut to
him if we could when he's ready we have
to get him out of his cuffs out of his
mask he's in currently in a in a
Cell oh Charlie uh a viewer named
Charlie donated and said all your
costumes look good well thank you to
Charlie thank you Charlie you love
Charlie we love Charlie
absolutely so we have had uh Malik good
friend of the show he is our dedicated
door maker yes we had him build us a
door with two
locks on our persons we will have two
keys okay we will run to the door as
we're being pursued by Michael Myers the
question is there he is [__] dude that's
scary right
there oh man all right who is that get
back in his
cell that's actually
scary and so as you see in the horror
movies so many times they're running the
keys you can't quite get the keys in but
the monster right behind you Michael
Myers will be in Hot
Pursuit will you get through the door
I've had nightmares like that so many
times so we're going to do it as like a
kind of a
competition as we all get eliminated to
see who is the last one standing and you
know in in slasher films there's always
one last person standing and so that is
what we'll be doing here today uh in
honor of Michael Myers I asked I asked
Malik that's his seventh door for us is
that right how did we do that seven is
he including the two bathroom ones we
broke yeah probably yeah that makes cuz
he does that means he made four for the
live show that sounds right he says he
fixed a different door down stairs too
oh the other bathroom right cuz we broke
like every bathroom that guy is such a
[__] he like rolls up and he's
backing his Trucking and [__] he's got
[__] like Sig in his mind like what's
up dude how you doing man he's such a
[__] character that guy yeah he is he
really is we love Malik and I love that
he's just turned into like our handyman
we just call him and give him work yeah
why not he always Happy's good at his
job yeah he's great he's slick talented
guy and he makes really good uh
Collectibles uh that light up the
runway so that's coming up we also have
a pumpkin carving
contest everyone carved a punk bin I'm
going to try to guess who's is who
except there was a little wrench in our
gear they all rotted the [__] out
they're [__] disgusting bro you guys
carved them on Wednesday and they're
literally rotting full of mold and vile
vile
disgusting and we ran into this at home
too we carved pumpkins with Theodore and
by the next day it's like already
disgusting so I don't understand what am
I missing we were wondering is there
something happening because when I was a
kid I don't recall the pumpkins going
bad that fast you could carve the
pumpkin you could leave it out on your
doorstep for a while before it doesn't
fully rot I mean my goodness that's what
I thought it would be like but I've
never done that before I just feel like
Halloween spirit doesn't exist anymore
more so I think maybe that's like a
physical uh sense of it like I feel like
the whole Halloween spirit is just gone
wait what do you mean do you think I
just I don't know I just I feel like Co
like really took a lot of like that joy
in the holidays out of like doing them
again you know I feel like Co changed a
lot and you think the pumpkins rotting
is like a manifestation of the lack of
sight gist absolutely the pumpkins
caught Co because Halloween is my
[__] favorite holiday like I love
that [__] and like I would go to
Halloween stores year round I just what
do people say that spirit is not there Z
let me examine your statement how old
are you uh 26 and when did um when did
Co start like four or five years ago now
2020 2020 yeah 2020 so you were how old
when Co started uh 23 you were just
rounding out your college Years yeah
you're an old [__] man now dude no
it's not even that it's just like other
people feel it too it's just not like
that I we travel too you have to go to
certain neighborhoods I think for us
having kids makes Halloween very much
alive maybe if we didn't have kids I
would probably feel the same way as you
right dude it's happening if you go to
the right neighborhoods in in La it's
crazy down there it's like a [__] 5x5
mile block party of Madness dude come
down come down there dude okay a lot of
people in the chat agree with you Zach I
just I don't know not the only one it's
like a loss of Innocence almost in a
sense and I don't know I'm just getting
way too existential crisis with this but
this is kind of [__] you up I mean
maybe it's my you know costume but um
yeah I I don't know it's it's it's kind
of depressing in a way you know Jesus
man yeah I know cool I have fun
today oh I I I'm not going to lie I felt
what you're saying before I had kids
yeah the truth is the magic wears the
magic wears but then when you have kids
the magic is born a new yeah a it is we
all going to trick orre as we have elor
costumes Bruce Teddy me my brother
sister-in-law and the two grandmas the
two grandmas we're all going to be DED
up
D yeah we flew out my mom actually here
because it was she was not doing well in
Israel so yeah um but it's so fun like
they like they're still young so they're
still kind of shock that hallowen
something like Halloween could even
exist where you go up and people give
you candy and let me remind you for kids
candy is literally currency it's gold
they're is pure gold that's it and so
just H it's it's it's beautiful it
really is fun well I look forward in
joining you guys to try and get my
Halloween spirit back all right yeah you
want to come I'll tell you where we're
going not I don't want to do it on yeah
you want to come with us maybe I mean
you should oh my God it really is fun
neighborhood we go to is crazy and fun
we can talk about it after this show
yeah but like if you're in LA or any
major city and you feel like that just
Google like which neighborhood should I
trick or treat in the truth is when I
was a kid I lived in this big
sprawling uh Suburban
neighborhood that there was like a
bajillion houses just clammed together
and so that neighborhood was where
everybody came to trick or treat so I
thought the whole world was like that
but the whole world is is not like that
right so you got to you got to make the
effort everywhere we've lived since I've
moved here hasn't been like a trick or
Trea neighborhood right people just like
it's silence because you go and also
because when you're a kid the parents do
everything to make sure your Halloween's
great you don't have ever have to think
about it and then you're an adult you
walk outside you're like yo where is
everything where is everything you know
yo I did a poll is the Hollywood Spirit
alive and well and it is dead 5050 in
our audience wa wow that's so
interesting oh it just took 51 yes I
just hit it to 51 oh man what a king I
brought it back you just saved Halloween
dude you're welcome everybody it's like
you know you know in uh you that movie
Elf you know where like Santa slay only
operates off like Christmas spirit like
that there you think that's real I just
yeah I I really do think you it's and
I'm a [__] Jew so it's you come with
us Zach it could be cool we'll revive
you I'll we need to revive the spirit
I'll defate because I I used to feel
like you but I'm telling you these
neighborhoods these people they love
Halloween like almost every house is
decorated like to the tea sure yeah yeah
I actually was expecting way more of
Halloween here cuz in Sweden we don't
really I mean we do but not like here
but I I don't see it that much either
again okay you got to join I'll tell
which neighborhood to go to if you guys
just want to go
there
um but uh There It Is Halloween The
Magic is alive for 50% of
us the last time I went trick retreating
I walked up to this house and the guy
was like I thought he was talking to me
he goes do you want a chicken nugget or
it was like chicken nugget or french
fries or something I I was [__]
stupid I was like a chicken nuggets I
guess and he goes oh I'm sorry I was
talking to my daughter he goes but the
candies right there and I that was take
the Nuggets bro every time Halloween
comes around I cringe thinking about
that it's funny but I feel like you're
maybe being too hard on yourself maybe I
don't know at the time it was pretty
[__]
embarrassing you want chicken nuggets or
french fries you were about to eat his
nuggets
bro I think I was like so anxious I just
like I just like answer quick and then
so I just said whatever but yeah it's so
[__] weird would you have eaten the
nugs if he gave them to you at that
point in my life probably yeah
yeah H Man Halloween is so fun and you
when I was a kid man we and I'm grew up
in Ventura the east side of Ventura if
you've been there it's literally just
how it's just like single family houses
forever and so the amount of houses you
could crush in a night was bananas we
used to take pillows case suitcases
pillow cases I mean and fill those
[__] up I use pillowcases up dude
really oh so you went hard too oh yeah
absolutely are you kidding me right I
had an older sister she knew exactly
what to do I I loved Halloween so much
as a kid I used to do like three costume
changes oh my God you yeah come on you a
theatrical boy I was I [__] loved it
so much we'll get it back that's it
we'll get it back all right I appreciate
it thank you did you guys ever get like
Bibles when you went trick-or-treating
like little tiny ones that's insane I I
thought it was a common thing and I
brought it up here a while ago and no
one else got
that it was literally little tiny
booklet Bible if you hand out a Bible on
Halloween in my neighborhood your you
your house gets burned down that's how
you die that yeah you're asking for Te
it was it it was book and it was like
attached like a Reese's Peanut Butter
Cup it was I swear to God damn it so
yeah it was weird you know that's like
uh that's just not cool man you know
what I mean not
today cool uh so there it
is there it
is I have a big announcement I want to
this is a call out to everybody watching
here with peace and love this is a
serious message we are going to be doing
new competition okay it's been a long
time since we've had one I love and we
have now what I think is the perfect
medium all right so as you guys know
dream the musical artist has blessed us
with this fantastic single yes
nightmare it's so good well then there's
the Sleep version oh okay I thought I
thought you wrote that song No but he
wrote he right I he wrote like a little
bit
oh he was in the room he was in the
room play my song Zach or did he do a
cover of yours you know what you know
what Ela I can't remember I think he did
Cover mine I think I wrote it and he
covered M that's what I thought that's
what I thought you said now that you say
that it drops the memory of me yeah
yeah okay so everyone in the audience
I'm pretty sure has been absolutely
consumed mentally by this song all
weekend
and so here people have started to make
remixes here's one for example I can't
breathe when you're not here the
Orchestral Version and this is
phenomenal oh fous on the cello yeah so
[Applause]
triumphant wow so
[Music]
epic
[Applause]
there
when you're not there there not
there so my my call out to all of
the Hooper Trooper
nation is that I want your
best sleep uh sleeps nightmare song
that's available for 99 cents on Amazon
it was really good um it's a so I want
to hear all your remixes mhm M so submit
them you have until the end of the
weekend today's Monday I would like to
do this on a week from today on Monday
is that giving them enough time because
I also don't want the joke to go too
long I oh wa we won't do it on Monday
we'll do it on Wednesday I think we'll
do it on Wednesday I think next Monday
should be the cut off right is that
enough time okay give it a week for uh
production and a half a week for mixing
yeah so so you no no they'll have to be
submitted on Monday it's to give us a
time to then comp all the submission
maybe we should give him two weeks you
know maybe we should like a week and a
half so maybe maybe Wednesday and then
we can do it on Friday right okay
fornite okay so next Wednesday as Zach
said you get a week for production half
a week for mastering the tracks right
okay I'm putting it on the calendar
right now fortnite deadline so everybody
please get and remember if you do upload
it to YouTube that's fine I will claim
it it is my
IP
but it's fine if you want to upload that
to YouTube I do give you permission but
uh yeah just so you know don't be
surprised oh my God
yes yeah um that's very
exciting there's been a few other dream
remixes um Ethan Klein
remixes right I mean sleep remixes why
are you yeah you're like giving them all
this Cloud for free uh can you go ahead
and play my song again one more time
just to get in the vibes
when you're not there not there you're
not there can't when you're not there
it's a nightmare it's
nightmare can't when you're not
there it it's giving like thirde eyye
blind and that's a dude Third Eye Blind
is my
[__] it's it kind of it is a [__]
legit billboard hit uh-huh uh-huh I wish
you would step down from that ledge my
friend yeah
exactly when you're
not can I
graduate can I
graduate okay I see there's another
thirde eyye blind fan in the room oh you
know you know Z and I graduate can I get
my P I'm not doing
that I love that Alum thir ey blind it's
the one thing that Ethan and I will not
agree on you're such a hater with one we
have the same taste in everything but I
cannot get behind that one I listened to
that whole album probably like twice a
year I'll just put it on and then every
time every time he puts it on I'm like
she's so out like oh my God sometimes I
wonder like are you joking are you
trolling me it's a perfect album It's
AUM first of all there's a lot of
nostalgia happening that being said
beautiful Lyricist the music Insane
okay every song on that track is a Bop
right Zach oh it's a perfect 10 out of
10 record one of the first uh that's one
of the first CDs I ever bought really
really you too behind it oh yeah yeah no
I'm fully with Ethan on this one I'm
sorry that was the self-titled album let
me see what it let me see how it was
reviewed at the time I'm kind of curious
the uh C oh [__] it has a really high
rating on all music that album is as old
as I am that [__] me up dude wait Ela
I got to say you know you're being this
is a this is a classic album the people
have spoken look at that yeah are you
all like ironically liking
it to make it cool also from a a
production standpoint James Valentine
the producer of that record [__]
iconic amazing producer really yeah I
don't know a lot of their songs but I
like all the ones that I do now there's
like three or four songs I really like
Listen to self-title album dude it's
insanely good semi semi charm life is a
class yeah sem that's the one song I ski
just cuz I've heard it so many times but
I mean the lyrics are so I don't know
like it's both smok and meth I love I
love the song it's just like when I was
a kid it was on the radio so much you
know what I mean it's like oh man not
this one like I'm a huge fan of the band
but every time the weight comes on which
is their famous song I skip it I can't
listen to it how does that one
go famous famous like I would know it
too yeah it's the one song that
everybody knows there it goes uh D do
one the way it goes [__] now I can't
remember the melody hold on let me play
for one that's no he's talking about the
moved on from which one are you on now
he's talking about The Band The Weight
the band I love I'm I'm a
huge yeah I was feeling about 10 you
don't like it I love it I just I don't
want to hear it anymore I feel that I
feel you song played out it's like it's
the lead single everybody knows you a
fantastic song don't get me wrong the
band had some [__] amazing Tunes I
love the absolutely one of the most
criminally underrated classic rock
bandly and Tra really a tragic ending
for all of them frankly yeah I mean
Robbie just died really yeah what the
guitar player Robbie Robertson he was
the only one that actually made it out
of that one like with some money yeah
wait he died yeah what idiot
dumb yeah those of you guys who know the
band lore I think most true band fans do
not like Robbie
Robertson because he basically he
survived he's the one that
survived as the other guys tell it he
basically they didn't know how song
writing credits worked so he would write
the lyrics and he's like yeah so I'll
just put that down and then when it came
out when they started you know having a
huge body of work he was getting all the
royalties and these guys were not
getting [__] paid at all and a lot of
these dudes died broke which is just
tragic so yeah he died huh
yeah August 2023 very recently I mean he
he's a great talent by the way and a
great Lyricist it's just a shame that he
[__] over his band mates so hard they
were all so
talented yeah I could go on on about
them but that's not the theme of the day
but check out the
band dude every person in that band is a
lead
vocalist every single one of them except
for Robbie he couldn't sing for [__]
except for Robbie
right I love their names too I love
Richard Manuel G and leevin Helm you
guys want to know how so Richard Emanuel
who's got the most beautiful voice of
all time incredibly gifted pianist
killed himself he was an alcoholic
killed himself and then uh Levan l h
died of throat cancer and he died like
poor he was like struggling and I don't
think he died poor but he was struggling
I love a drummer too like he was really
great Dano also like got had a tragic
death didn't he Rick Dano I don't know
what I don't remember what an anvil fell
on his
head Rick the Dan Dano yeah I think he
died young too age 55 yeah that's young
right I think he let me see I know this
is probably not interesting to
anyone he died after a brief tour I'm
fascinated bro it's a car uh he had a
heart attack heart attack oh he he got
really big and he was like a smoker and
yeah he was doing like little ass clubs
and it's just such a shame this man is a
just a anyway listen to the band thank
[Music]
you I don't even know what he's thinking
my heart go
on
[Music]
my oh my
God
sing I Know You
lyrics [__] I know I know
you you know talking about songs that
you just skip but while recognizing
they're very good I mean the Beatles has
so many songs that I have to skip like
Lucy and the Sky with Diamonds I can't
listen to it love the song I can't
listen to it Lucy and the sky the one
from Sergeant Pepper that I always skip
is uh uh the Mr Kite song The like clown
the clown core song I like that one
like that one it's just I don't hate it
but I've heard it enough that's I feel
that way that's that wasn't a radio hit
no it wasn't but I've heard it enough uh
a lot of their super pop songs I just
can't listen to yeah the most I
personally my favorite song of Sergeant
Pepper she's leaving home that song
[__] oh god oh what a song it's
insane did you hear about the new Beetle
song coming out no yeah they're uh she's
going back
home thanks I got it yeah yeah I got it
I got it um they uh I guess there was
some John Lennon vocals that like they
uncovered and then George laid some
guitar down in like the 90s and now like
Paul and Ringo got together and like
they're mixing it and it comes out I
think next month H I'm there you got
Paul Ringo together I'm there man okay
you have one song that you cannot listen
to which Kendrick Lamar oh he's got this
one and you got I'm a Hu I'm like a
massive Kendrick Lamar fan I know all of
his tracks on all of his albums he has
this one song on uh section 80 or no
it's D is it Dam yeah I think it's on he
has one similar on Project a I can't
listen to but he did a collab with you
too and I swear to God it is the worst
[__] trash when they come on I I I I
lose my mind what was he thinking trip X
is that the name of yeah like half of
the song is great when it's just him and
then the back half he brings Bono in to
do these horrific [__] it was such a
nightmare the intro to that song is good
yeah yeah I don't know but every time it
comes on Ethan gets like upset what was
he thinking Bono like what are you doing
man Bono's got to stay in the spere dude
I feel like he lose streak head by
having Bono on that track I think you
two is the most under overrated excuse
me overrated [__] B ever I got to
agree with you they are not good bro
Edge sucks dude hold on hold on they
have let's not take everything away from
you two they are a prolific they're
prolific prol and they have a ton of
great H there's a lot of it being great
song that being said what beautiful day
great
s stunning song and you know what's dope
about beautiful day like they have
already been around for so long and then
they came out with like one of their
best songs and everyone that song was
just sick everyone was like yo this
sounds F my opinion their their first
record is probably their best album boy
that album [__] is amazing yeah the
early YouTube stuff is okay do you guys
remember how they just uploaded one of
their albums on everyone's iPhone and
like you told me about it yeah well you
know the the show that like notoriously
did horribly on Broadway Spider-Man turn
off the dark written by Bono oh no
Bono's taking so many
L's Bono did do the music for turn off
the dark oh but um overall though if
you're I think massive YouTube fans and
I'm generalizing so don't I'm I
apologize if you're offended but people
who are like massive YouTube fans are
generally how do I put this hovering
over the button watch it the Buton I I
can picture what you're saying without a
dang it they're just like pretentious
[__] no I I wasn't even I was going
to say like uh just corny ass Boomers I
don't know they're just like the
corniest dumbest lamest Boomers going to
be
it's a little corny and like it kind of
blows my mind like they're the first
band to play in that that sphere in
Vegas like there's so many more Amazing
bands that can play they're really
popular yeah they have that name appeal
that not many bands today I don't think
any band today has that name
appeal not one you two like a rock and
roll band I mean they're all dead man
BTS BTS that
be than you is ever dude that eye would
have been stormed that eye would have
pink eye
[Laughter]
just be storn by all the adoring fans
who love BTS as much as me right right
and I love them trust me crazy St all
right we're talking about music or what
oh yeah I wanted to say if you are
planning on making a remix this is a
warning with peace and love make sure
you don't have any copyrighted sounds or
music in it I recommend uploading it to
YouTube first and seeing if it's is
claimed cuzz if it's claimed we cannot
play it on the show with peace and love
yes we will check them all that
happened last time with what was it it
was the diss track I think was the Ryan
kavanau diss tracks and so there was
some really good ones but they had to be
uh not included would it be fair to say
that uh your chance would be higher if
you make your own beat rather than no I
don't think so no yeah I don't think
everybody will know how to do that
necessarily but could still
be Ted what about epidemic sound can we
yeah I think that I listen if you up
sometimes when you use epidemic you'll
get a claim on it that says no effect
that's fine it say there no effect but
if you get a monetization claim then
we're not going to be able to play
it because I don't have ads I don't have
sponsors anymore peace and love you know
what I mean I can't come out here do
shows for
free uh that being said Thank you to our
members now Mars said she's going to
unsub
because they are a YouTube
fan I listen I used to be a massive
YouTube fan so I'm I I stand with you
however Kenny said Bono is a turd no he
he actually is a turd Bono seems kind of
like super cringy dude I'll say this
I've met the edge he seems like a really
cool nice dude he Al wait you met the
edge I had a I had a whole [__] din
din together what the [__] what cuz
Moses worked for his family for a while
I don't I don't know cuz I'm not I'm not
up to date but he was really close with
their family and so um you I met him a
few times really and we actually I sat
next to him at dinner I smoed with him
quite a bit all our friendes were
actually really close at one point did
you did you see what's under talking
[__] about you
too do you see what's under his hat I've
always wondered man it's a [__] shiny
Dome I
imagine but he's actually he seems like
a cool dude very nice guy yeah nice guy
we love Edge he does make everyone call
him Edge which is a little weird yeah
wait actually I think the people around
him call him Edge like even his wife oh
my god oh his real name is Adam right
yeah I don't I don't actually know he's
real name the edge they don't say the
edge they call him Edge Edge getting
here
Ed his name's David or David oh
David David Evans Bono or like mono cuz
you make me want to have small pox see
Bono's name is actually really cool it's
like Paul Houston or something like that
like that name that's not bad s that
cool I think it's better than
Bono anyway we love uh the Ed wait what
is it actually Paul David Paul
Houston pretty cool name I can't breathe
when you're not there you're not
there you're not there you're not there
I can't
sleep when your nightmare a nightmare a
nightmare here we go
I can you hit that note wow only you can
hit that note Ethan with your singing
[Music]
here like
that too early in the episode too early
built huh so I'm looking forward to that
very much so oh love it's your birthday
today it's
what
what oh my God hit the button start the
show over thank you restart we love love
he's in America we love love we love
love love is love and love you can
decide what to eat for for food yeah
your call and what to drink okay I I
have an idea okay cool I won't say it
loud
[Music]
yep y that was right that but I I
blurted out something that was too oh my
God oh my
God that's fine you just you just want
for
dude that was crazy I just said our
address that was pretty
C the one time you remember our address
yeah good point you got to explain what
happened there you want KATU Curries at
that Japanese shitel uh they have a
bunch of stuff they have like um shake
and pork anything did you really do that
again should we what I do no this time
is fine what I do I thought you weren't
supposed to say the name yeah it's it's
oh I said c should I hit it again no is
it a chain no no no no it's like just a
food that it's pretty General katsu
curry it's a type of quisine a type of
[Music]
quese that's okay they have salads and
stuff too for you guys okay okay so it's
a chicken cutlet with curry okay let's
[__] do this right now then it's
really yummy and um I don't know it's
probably one of my favorite meals what
do you order there I'm going to get what
you get I'm going to get a chicken KATU
curry with a extra Cur
and then is there rice or mashed potato
there's rice with it by default you can
add a little side of salad a little side
of that you there's also like cats so
I'm not going to say more but yeah there
there's a bunch of stuff it's healthy
healthy options I hope okay I hope
there's there's a vegg option there's VG
option yeah okay cool cool there it is
send the menu thank you thank you guys
thank you everyone in sh sh and our
address is located
at I I think it's worth saying what the
reason we bought was Ethan was making a
joke that he
was accidentally reading our address but
he actually said our actual address
almost half of it half of it go to all
right exting thank you guys go that's
why the button here can you imagine if I
couldn't button that out
yeah imagine life before the button oh
it's hard to I got in a lot of trouble
dark man you know it's like there's
really a pre and there's pre and post
button eras on the show and the button
is
just I'm getting emotional
things I'm going to need a minute what
was that gift we reacted to last time
the guy crying I wish I knew oh the
Vince mcmah yeah that Meme went crazy
this it's so funny it is very funny I
will say that I love it there's been a
lot of funny ones on the subreddit let
me see here I got one I'll send you
right
I can't dream as a
nightmare Brea God not
again as many times as I hear it it is
fresh every single time this is the
people at home um who hear dream again
and they have it stuck in their head all
week yep I I I want to know what he was
actually crying
about dude Vince McMahon is such a
character like even the way like who
does that it's so theatrical he's very
theatrical well he just run a theatrical
company for pretty much his entire life
McMan um the actual last name I think so
Vince McMahon yeah that's kind of
crazy yeah he owns the WWE he's an
interesting guy you say he's a piece of
[__] I don't anything about him uh yeah
I mean he's very controversial I'm not a
huge any true wrestling fan could
explain it way better than me but he's
had a lot of controversies with how he's
run the business how he treats the uh
the wrestlers and everything um oh like
okay so it's about just kind of how he
how he runs the business got it yeah
I've heard lots of people say uh
actually I think he also has like sexual
assault allegations well that see that's
that's I I found out why he's crying it
was about the Undertaker and what he
meant to WWE they asked him about they
believe he I could start crying about
the Undertaker man let's see he had a
steroid supplier uh trial oh there you
go sexual misconduct sexual misconduct
let's see former referee noted for her
stint wait she was a ref the first
female ref oh there you go the first
female ref and Vince McMahon's got a
[__] oh no this is
horrible she claimed he tried to okay so
I'm not going to even read it this is a
fun
episode like I said there's there's a
lot there so he's a but he is a he is a
cartoon character he's in some funny
gifts so he sure is there's that one of
him and Trump fighting that is Iconic
too right oh that's him yeah oh yeah and
the one of him progressively getting
more and more excited there's a BN
there's tons of McMahon means ter what
what you're
doing um let's see oh my God you guys
are going to love this Dave rubben who
we talk about occasionally Dave Reuben's
a a married gay guy
that's true actually true Dave ruin is a
conservative commentator and token can I
call him a token or is that not my place
to say h it's not your place to say
right but I mean at the same time his
friends and they say I don't I will
never attend your wedding even your
anniversary I will never attend it
because that is what Ben Shapiro said
and he says he goes that's fine he
literally says that's fine and I love
that we can talk about it that's like me
sitting down with a Nazi being like I
don't think you should exist I think you
should be dead and everyone like you and
I'll be like that's cool at least we can
sit down and have a
conversation
now now what he really is the worst he's
a [__] and uh he is just the worst
Hitler I don't know if I can call him a
tolken CU it's not my place true but if
it was my
place but it's not if it was my place I
also wouldn't say it because uh that's
for other people to point out not for me
to point
out all right so here um he's on
whatever podcast which just from the
beginning is funny because
this he's like he's not a dating guy
it's like so far from what he is and uh
the majority of this panel he s he sits
there in total
silence it's just so awkward but here
this one girl brings up the um the
fabled the name of the uh the outcast
the the forbidden Sam Cedar and he
freaks the [__] out and walks
off these guys they're what yeah here it
is I'll play it your conversations on
your thing would you ever debate Sam
Cedar no he's a horrible horrible human
being no you wouldn't debate him no why
do they say he like horrible human being
he's not they make it sound like he
killed someone yeah so funny do they
just oh well so Dave ruin and Sam have a
history cuz Sam has made like a thousand
videos on him uhuh and a lot of
conservatives accuse him of harassing
Dave which is just so funny cuz Dave is
a [__] [__] he deserves to be
lampooned right yeah uh
but this man thinks he's think the CL I
think the claim is actually greatly
exaggerated from what I understand it's
not like they've talked a thousand
videos about not a thousand but there's
like probably nearly a hundred okay fair
enough no it's a lot but it's but I have
no problem with it I mean he's he's out
there in the arena yeah you know it's
the
arena no no but you're into like open
exchange of ideas and stuff right no
they have a yeah how many see
exactly how many videos on this playlist
uh there's
171 so they're not exaggerating okay it
is over the course of it looks like
that's a lot I mean we're talking like
seven years here or something so well
not that's a long period of it's still a
but that's a lot of videos
and that's a lot of videos yeah human
being why no cuz he's done like a
thousand videos about me that are all
nonsense I've never even talked even
like the hyperbolic exaggeration though
is 15% true
thousand about him what a what a boring
way to not boring what an unfortunate
way to have me walk off no he's like a
really terrible person I so he these
guys they they're
so they're so lame they they crumbled
they didn't even know how to handle it
yeah like just have you not thought
about how like just say you know what
he's a smart guy I'll think about
talking to him sometime or like you know
what like he you know maybe I'll think
about it I I'll think about it but I
don't think I'm interested yeah I'm just
not a huge fan but uh CU he you know he
seems mean-spirited but you know at the
same time I'll think about it maybe uh
they crumble and they turn it into these
scenes where they look so moronic go
ahead Z maybe he had to take a a wicked
[__] and this was the excuse to get up
no I just think you you can't say his
name he's like [__] Voldemort to
these people they're terrified of
him he's a Voldemort to the really the
right wing yeah and I mean it makes
sense that he would have a lot of videos
on him I mean you have a guy a gay man
who's like openly siding with a bunch of
people who are anti lgbtq Community I
mean it is it is something to talk about
he's a he's a me machine he is beyond
that just a colossal [__] like this man
went on Joe Rogan
and like of all the rightwing people
that Joe has this revolving door for he
just Joe destroyed he made him look
joean you can tell Joe Rogan is like
this guy is just dumb as rocks which
like that's Joe Rogan saying that like
he Dave Rubin went on Joe Rogan he's
like we don't need regulations the Le
the rest the less regulations the better
and Joe's like well I worked I grew up
working in construction and we
definitely need regulations cuz those
guys need to be told that safety
regulations cuz they'll cut corners and
Dave was trying to argue about how
regulations are bad and then he he
basically backed out of it and Joe Rogan
never invited him back on he cries about
it he goes I've reached out to Joe to
get back on the show but I haven't heard
back it's like sad he's so pathetic so
sad and
pathetic anyway here it is get into the
internet to like just endlessly destroy
everybody and everything else I like
talking to people that I can have
enlightened conversations with and like
some people just want endless
Destruction for uh I think you should
give not a Paris man
funny you know I like to have you know
conversation with people like Ben
Shapiro who do you think's one who says
he would never come to my wedding right
exactly as ask Sam if he
would well not yours specifically but
you know what I mean that clip is just
so
sad I watched that way too it's so sad
you know but a good one yeah have a
chance I think you guys would have a
really good conversation oh you're a
troll I knew something was up with you
this whole time
not no no no I I couldn't quite figure
it out with you but all right you don't
get the book you guys get the book oh
wow thanks for coming I don't think any
ofone want your book
[Music]
Dave leave phone he Rage Quit out
of
thank thanks for coming the [__] was
Dave ruin on this [__] weird ass red
Bill dating show like what he's
desperate you know he's desperate he
sees that and that's just because she
mentioned him imagine if they actually
pulled up Sam Cedar like you did oh my
God you know or um what's his name
Crowder his wife is ruined so I I guess
I understand they think he is like a
he's a curse if they ever get on a call
with him like happened with Crowder
their life will be ruined he'll get
divor he'll lose his house he'll get
fired you
know open heart he's a bad Omen right
open he's a bad Omen man [__] watch
it so that's it I just find it
incredible that he
can't he can't handle it with Grace he
has to [__] has to be a little baby and
piss and pout and he looks so dumb and
he turns it into such an embarrassing
calling her a troll she showed no signs
of like trolling him she was just asking
why wouldn't you talk to him I would
love to see that's that's a shame of it
is that I would love to see these
conversations with between Sam and some
of these people you know it would be
great well that's Dave Rubin for you
guys uh beautiful and certainly it's
going to be adding another video to
their playlist on Dave ruin I'm sure you
one or two one or two maybe
three um all right I got to go to the
bathroom when we come back let's do our
first segment of you want to do the
pumpkins or the Jason you want do the
pumpkin one first I think not Jason you
keep calling them Jason it's they're the
same in my mind they're kind of like
they're not but I get what you mean
Jason Michael Myers both scary big guys
with masks on so like they're you know
they got knives they walk slow yeah they
got masks right is this like a Burger
King McDonald's type of thing different
franchises but same kind of taste all
different flavors I mean look at these
[__] it's the same damn [__] oh
yeah that is the same thing well they
have Michael vers Jason uh okay so which
one are we doing Michael or Jason
Michael okay we're doing Michael
Michael's the one with the hockey mask I
guess which is the No No Jason is is the
one with the hockey mask Michael is a
Michael's a William Shatner mask inside
out isn't it yes it is actually that's
that's the shat right
there is that right yeah the mask is a
modified William Shad oh Jesus aome why
are their names so normal you know Jason
and Michael they started as normal
people but they became corrupted and
current David and Paul can't believe
this yeah Jason uh drowned in a lake and
so he's kind of like Undead his mother
drowned him in a lake a ho l or
something yeah a permanent
timeout uh whereas Michael what is mik
Michael's a little more Supernatural
Lena's the expert yeah well he's just a
child he started by killing his sister
and and then he's just been demented
since then he's just super evil wacky
why doesn't someone shoot him if he's
just a guy and the newer ones there's
more of a supernatural son of a I wonder
about the superheroes too why don't
people just do that well at least like
you know super are strong if Michael
Myers is just a dude with a knife just
[__] shoot him it's hard to say
because they change it up for like every
movie they destroy franch at this point
but yeah she knows it's just it's funny
to me cuz she doesn't know a lot about
movies well we first met but the amount
of lore she knows about Michael Myers
and like where it branches off it's it's
it's so funny to me Michael getting shot
is literally how the first movie ends
too yeah I was going to say but that's
what's confusing cuz then there's like
18 more movies so at some point it
becomes Supernatural he's not just a
normal dude well he's here in the studio
so he's we can ask him yeah so um all
right we're going to do our Pumpkins I'm
just going to let me get some of that
katsu shimatsu with uh you get extra
Curry is that necessary um there's a
little it's like 20% too little food I
stay off the screen Ian I'm going to
click the menu yeah it's like 20% too
little food so I always reduce a little
bit thing is I don't like rice I wonder
if I could get
a I think I'm the only person alive that
doesn't like rice C cheese fries bro
pasta you don't like pasta or rice why
it's not okay so it's not that I don't
like pasta I just but you won't eat it I
would never order it in my ever even if
we get it you don't eat I don't like it
because okay especially now that I'm
like very conscious about my calories
always like past that's true but even as
a fat man I didn't eat it that's what
I'm saying even before cuz pasta is one
of the most calorie dense empty calorie
dish you can have and I don't even enjoy
that pizza well pizza I like at least
you
know I want those curry cheese fries bro
pizzas actually
nous sometimes I order a side of fries
just for the to dip in the
curry exactly me too just lovely love
rice wood sauce oh yeah um spicy what's
Cara
age huh is a spicy cheddar Cara age is
it kage or like the one of the fried
little Shakin it's probably good
whatever it is just go for it it's
karagi I don't know if that's Ki karagi
Oh it's like little uh nuggies yeah
little oh my God the dessert you got a
dessert there definitely wait there's
dessert here shees it is ridiculous wait
I got to talking about Nutella stuffed
cookie all right I'll get that too I'll
have a bite of yours oh my God so no uh
cookies for you that looks crazy
whoa so I'll just get what love getting
plus the fries
okay and a spring
salad wow so love is getting what again
did did somebody write that down or
should I write it in the okay thanks um
I got shicken KATU with extra Sal exra
rice be right back and then we're going
to do our segment
okay sounds good
okay uh where did my window go I got too
many [__] Windows here
second sorry guys I hate doing this on
the
show hate doing what like ordering food
and focusing on something else we got to
find a long-term solution here you guys
got to do this before the show we did it
on Friday it was so successful so
successful it's we're always we're
already always rushing right at the last
minute to get up on air so it it falls
by the wayside sorry sh sh we're
ordering food right now
[Music]
a [__] [__] that's pretty good chain
look looks legit oh thank you yeah is
that real Is that real diamonds yeah is
a billion dollars holy [__] when we saw
him at that party he was standing in
front of me at like I forget he was
ordering but I just I couldn't stopped
looking at it it was like the [__]
ring from Lord of the Rings was just
talking to me I like yo man let me hold
that chain real
quick okay I got um a request for baby
bump
update so let me tell you guys I am week
uh I never remember I think s yeah week
17 I I just did the math I think
yesterday and I think I just finished
the fourth month wow it's crazy wow oh
my God congratulations yeah how do you
feel I feel fine totally fine but I've
been having a lot of headaches yeah and
I don't know if it's because of the
pregnancy or I don't know it could be
honestly just watching the news so much
normally I don't I don't ever watch the
news right I hate it but now I'm
watching it
nonstop
terrible
um but yeah and then I have haven't had
any checkup in a while but I have one
tomorrow so I don't really have any
updates sometimes I'm like hey are you
still there is everything
okay do you have specific cravings for
food that you didn't have with um it's
not so much it's just that like I'm way
easier with food like I just get so
hungry I'll eat anything and I enjoy
everything which is really
fun um actually lots of chocolates and
sweets mhm have been a lot of like we
have some you want me to bring you some
candy we have some on the desk happy
Halloween well I ordered some of those
cookies for your appetizers yeah yeah oh
my God I got to bring in my the sweetest
chocolate I have at home you're going to
love it yes I go to IKEA once a month to
stock off on Candy really yeah oh my God
I didn't know that that was a thing I
was going to ask you if Ikea's is legit
because it is really good but I was just
curious if it's like you think it's up
to par the there's golden ones called
marabo that's the they have some low
sheep Branch how salt in it God salt
yeah salt salt just like anything like
sugar right now has been my we we got a
bag of candy look at this oh all right
guys are we done ordering thank you all
right so moving on every person has a
rotted out pumpkin here yes and we are
going to guess who carved that
pumpkin that's
right welcome everybody and happy
Halloween oh nice
[Applause]
graphic who pumpkin is
this well because everybody's favorite
game there's an active component to this
Ethan everybody's face is hiding behind
these pumpkins and I will reveal
them very exciting yeah that's cool yes
so let's let's begin is uh so ab's going
to go over there with his camera and
give us some close-ups
here of works of
[Music]
art I'll say this by the way
since we're not doing leftovers Thursday
has turned into a kind of a beautiful
day for us arts and crafts day these
guys were doing pumpkins all day I was
at home doing important stuff MH you
know kind of nice having that kind of
nice
[Music]
all right go ahead let's let's begin
with
uh with that one please
[Music]
yes now is fungus and mold
flammable cuz that would be interesting
to see you light in in fire I mean it's
yeah yeah definitely is is it combust
combustible I don't think it'll
explode but I don't know maybe if enough
gas builds up inside from like the
rotting that could get explosive who's
got a
lighter I can't see a closeup okay I got
to stop eating sorry guys I'm going
stop all right oh it's a dream is that a
dream pumpkin oh
yeah it's a nightm wow gorgeous gous a
nightmare it is a nightmare
who do the dream pumpkin who would who's
obsessed with the song more than
anyone who is the nightmare person I've
know I've heard Dan talk about it I
don't think Dan would do that though
would you say our sound guy that has to
deal with the sound the most I think
Zach likes
[Music]
it maybe it's maybe it's a all right I'm
going to go ahead and
say
also a bit lazy too someone who didn't
want to put too much effort
in which is something to consider
right
potentially potentially I'm going to go
ahead and say uh
o I'm going to say that it's love I'm
lazy that's not what I meant don't
there's no way I could name someone and
I don't think the lazy um argument is
valid here no I I I I take it back you
want do you want to make a separate
guess hea or you on board with love Ian
maybe look at all of
[Music]
you oh
really it's a
nightmare maybe it was Sam or Ian who
did that
one I have a little I have to admit I
saw which one is
Sam's and so I have to I have to come
clean about that you need to abstain or
or how do they call it in the Supreme
Court recuse recuse yourself M mhm all
right look show us who made the uh who
made the nightmare
pumpk Z oh no it was Zach okay call me
lazy dude right come on it's artistic
genius right there you were on the right
track Ela thank you damn listen to
Listen to Your Instinct so that do you
love the song or do you despise it's
it's growing on me but I thought it'd be
Wicked to do a dream pumpkin and I don't
know there's something creepy about it
like with his mask and uh I like it the
lines are good beautiful lines thank you
thank you beautiful line word it
actually took a long time to carve like
where it says Nightmare on the bottom
like actually took me a pretty long time
to do that so yeah taking back the lazy
uh the lazy Char very much so all right
moving on to the next pumpkin thank you
Z pumpkin
and these things are rotted out so it's
real soft right
Lena like show the inside pop that baby
open show them what we're working with
when I say rotted I mean rotted oh I
can't see that well but yeah shine a
[Music]
light you
okay well he didn't shoot
it
[Music]
a nightmare a nightmare a nightmare I
see the
nightmare
you're we are changing the battery
folks all right the battery is changed
we're back let's let's take a peek under
the
hood and we support all life all all all
life matters including this colony of
fungus oh that's fussy and
Coy this is
inclusive it's like X's room yeah what
do you mean by that
Doo and they're all like that from
Wednesday I don't know people are saying
of course it's like that you're in La
first of all it wasn't that it was
actually pretty cool this weekend and
second of all we didn't have them
outside we left them inside in a dry
cool place so you think we just Lefty
surprising they roted that quick maybe
we just bought the pumpkins on their
last leg this one is that possible the
batch was old no they they all looked
good when I got them I think it's
because they're organic a [__] I
think I saw it like the next day and
they looked great still I don't know I'm
always telling the audience everybody
listening I'm telling you guys the
organic [__] is it's it's a [__] SC I
don't think that's what it is though it
might be it might be because the GMO
they probably engineer that [__] to stay
nice and firm for a minute maybe oh yeah
I feel like organic prop goes bad faster
definitely cuz like the GMO stuff they
splicing in like goldfish jeans and
[__] alligator SLA yeah and then all
of a sudden you got super I I don't know
if what we had at home was organic and
it did that too I don't know either yeah
all right up
[Music]
next love your self with a picture of a
chicken I believe it's a bird a chicken
is a bird thank you I mean that's true
uh this is a Gary ve reference it's a
pigeon ah love yourself then what's with
the
pigon you really don't know is that an
nft it's an nft dude okay okay that's a
v friend wait
what no I know I know okay so that's a v
friend so there's like a famous NF with
a bird that art is too good for for V I
was expecting something worse all right
who's a g that's got to be oh man who's
a Gary ve hater here
Dano I say Daniel or camaran I would say
Cameron too but I feel like he'd be
doing something more artistic
mhm heavy okay yeah that's one of his
better defense frankly that's cute the
perspective
pigeon he looks proud of it hold the
[__] phone does it actually say
perspective pigeon that's what it is
holy [__] different perspectives bro are
you for real different perspectives no
get into a handstand or some weird
position and look at it again I like
that it's in a in a [__] cover like it's
so important
yeah he sold that dumb [__] for like
$100,000 or something back FS this is
literally me coming home from
kindergarten showing my parents right my
art
yeah all right who's I mean Cameron I
know is a v a vhe
head a vhe head like a pro vhe the vhe
head he's the one who he's the one who
introduc introduced us to uh kissing his
dad yeah no I don't mean you're a fan
you're just you know the lore yeah he's
my wall cow I think it is cam I think
it's
cam okay
Cameron am I supposed to say or is it
here they're pulling it
up I'm sorry but it was me love yourself
man what you did uh you did whoa whoa
whoa whoa what do you play copyrighted
music oh it's it's okay we tested it
what really yeah yeah really it's cuz
it's just like a four it's like a 3se
second clip of it the hell really yeah
really scary is a thing very good Dan
let thank you Dan has good advice
everybody at home love yourself wow do
you want to unpack that a little bit
it's just he been posting those stupid
videos on instagam you want to unpack
the meaning of it it feel like it's
pretty self-explanatory isn't I mean Den
has been loving how upset you get at
those so I I can see why he would go for
that just been he's been amused by the
whole thing quite a lot very good all
right up next who we
got Dan is the queen oh my God that one
has really B had a rough time okay here
I'm feeling actually the back here I'm
feeling cam what happened on the back
though for real I think there was a an
audible was called to try try something
else oh Cam that cam does do that where
he resps and this face does it remind
you of somebody is it it reminds me of
the sculpture of your
head so we're feeling Cameron on this
yeah okay
Cameron it's got to be
Cameron nobody else would restart on the
other
side that's the
fun you got it there he is suicide what
oh dead body over here oh my
God the opposite side was supposed to be
you going Goblin mode just my
justification the opposite side is crazy
yeah the opposite side is crazy so I
like how it
yeah it kind of looks cool I think
there's someone hanging right there oh
my
God very good uh thank you
Cameron all right what do we got
[Music]
next
okay okay I'm going to say it's a no you
didn't do
one you did not do
one so wait love did one right do we do
I think just AB we haven't uh I did I
made I made one you who haven't I named
we haven't named
Olivia we haven't named Lena Lena was
didn't do one did you oh you did do one
and we haven't named love right that's
right mhm so we have three left yeah you
just have Zach myself and cam so far
those three so I'm feeling that it's
love or lean on that
one love it or leave it love it or lean
it lean it
that's a good name for a dating show for
you love it or leave it love it or leave
it that's true good good name very good
name I'm feeling that it's um who do you
think Lena or or love uh or other
theories and we're not forgetting
anybody right that's everybody yes Ian
wait Ian yeah did we Sayan is a Poss do
that one he didn't do that one no but
he's still in the okay got yeah he's in
the running
okay um I don't
[Laughter]
know maybe Lena all right Lena we're
saying Lena the little devil that little
devil is very
cute who is it oh oh oh who's
that we did orange skin got
him
nice is that interesting we could tell
it was yours it's just a pumpkin
[Music]
yeah I don't know Vibes it's Vibes it's
just what kind of paint did you use on
your skin it looks like so natural it's
a mix
of
yes it's a mix of red lipstick and I
forgot what else I used we didn't have
red paint so I had kind of had to
improvise lipstick amazing red lipstick
from the um the Olivia makeup segment
hey girly oh my God shut up for real so
we had that night improved
wow that's why it looks kind of like um
just swollen up like that I think you
invented a new makeup applicator I think
you did thank you wait you have lipstick
all over your skin yeah what that's
crazy amazing all right
cool up next we
have another pumpkin coming at you
podcast whose pumpkin is that everybody
favorite game of the year we have
a what in
God's it's just a
face well it's a certain someone's face
you telling me you don't recognize is
that tree oh no it's the guy fibian or
whatever his name is I thought it's
Frankenstein you think it's fidus fidus
h fidus I think that was after they
carved the pumpkin theous
meme before all right who did this which
one of y'all did
this um
[__]
Ian yeah once it's pointed out to you
you're going to be like how did I not
know who that was really I I don't agree
with maybe should I just say yes say yes
that is Mr rectangular
himself
rectangular I kind of do see it I oh
it's green you yes and it's green as
well his hair should should have been
green I guess you can't do that all
right rectangular I mean I'm going to
I'm just going to say Ian yeah say Ian
who are you saying Ian okay stand by pan
Ian Ian
Ian doesn't it look like that guy though
too here we go oh oh oh is that a Mr
Beast logo Jimmy Beast did it again
there he is out of the Grave hold on I'm
we're actually doing better than it was
a rough start but now now we're doing
good I'm feeling the pumpkin yeah we're
loving the pumpkin well it's only going
to get easier cuz we have less and less
people we have uh remaining love uh Sam
and Olivia all right let's take a
look this this one is my favorite is
this okay no this just a heart with a
this one has completely Fallen apart
this is a decomposed heart with the lit
collap it's a heart that's all rotting
it's very meaningful just a heart very
deep is that an Olivia thing just heart
I think
so it is a it's a broke got to be I
think it's but always just girly things
Hearts just girly things all right who
is it the decomposed heart off the
charts but always in your decomposed
heart here it
[Music]
is it's Miranda s Miranda it's
Miranda it was beautiful once with the
heart was there something I just was
feeling like Halloween needed something
beautiful oh true true I was mhm I felt
that Wednesday so we have two left I see
we it was really beautiful when it
wasn't rotting thank you I just want to
show look how wet the they're leaving
this they're leaking dude smell it the
paper is all wet what it smell like yeah
what's it smell like I it's going to
smell it you don't have to I was a joke
but I'd smell it it doesn't smell like
anything you want to smell it sure I'll
smell it I believe you funny shot but
just because you know just to uh e it's
soaking wet yeah hold on you handed the
wet
side yeah it just smells like pumpkin
juice oh probably what it is it's like
soaking wet
nasty he was extremely wet sure was all
right so there's just two remaining and
here is the first of I know who did the
minion one who else could it be right
MOS yeah I mean Among Us here's what I'm
thinking
Sam she would do the minion cuz she's
like Po she's like post ironic humor you
know what I mean she has
very also the Artistry is quite good
okay but then if you look at but who
else is left love if you look at the
other one let's look at the other one
which is no pain
Lorraine I have to actually I have to
not say anything because I know which
one is Sam okay where's no pain Lorraine
by mistake yeah you can turn it
around um the no pain Lorraine one is
quite impressive in terms
of like I immediately recognize who that
is wow the negative space is like so
good it's so good so good yeah so
accurate that is honestly love oh my God
so but love would also be ironic and
maybe do
maybe do a Among Us you why does that
have to be ironic maybe they're just a
big fan of Among Us of Among
Us Among Us there's somebody who's a
dedicated fan I think Sam I'm just I
think Sam
did she because she's so post ironic
postcolonial ironic ISM Marxist Len I
don't know what Jordan Peterson says
right postmodern
uhan I think she did the the minion or
the [__] whoever the damn thing is
the Among Us the Among Us okay we ready
was it Sam was it Sam come on come on
come on I need this oh that blonde hair
doesn't look like Sam it's God I got two
in my head I got two in my head I am did
I I'm kind of like that too I like the
iink it I know you do I know you do and
that of course makes Sam the final thing
is the Artistry though on the not pain
Lorraine is good I'm also very honored
to be confused with or with samart too
cuz she always true does well she always
brings the heat compliment yours is
really good
love
yeah so there it
is and guys that's it with today we got
the pumpkin we got the rotting we got
the
mold we're having two much fun out here
folks oh my God there's glitter all over
my desk this is
horrible having too much
fun
Halloween so we have the Michael Myers
one still there's so much stuff to look
at still
though
um for example here's a phenomenon
that's been happening on Tik Tok and
I've seen a few people doing
this they're doing some kind of um
some kind of interesting H won't drag
over some kind of interesting hair does
here uh the bald men are tired of being
left out of the hair dude and so they've
constructed some kind
of I love this this is so sick proxy
resin what the hell and he's blowing
bubbles right out the
Dome um is this the guy that does it a
bunch he's having no
fun those are really nice bubbles he's
blowing oh this is just random [__]
posting bunch of gorilla posts what is
this what this I don't know what this
account is it's got 300 likes but he's
just posting a gorilla is a gorilla
dud what a
gorilla what a
gorilla
the what you're
saying [__] yes so um oh there's a whole
bunch but I guess we haven't found them
but I keep seeing these on my on my for
you page
I just like what there's so many
questions I'm assuming it's got to be a
joke right who is it for what's the
target audience cuz every single time
it's like a kind of a older it's like a
older dude that like would not find that
funny you know I don't know what's
happening here let's see the translation
why why why why why why is he satisfied
to pay for
him can youall try to find more of these
yeah also the
what the good news is that xqc actually
solved the Israel Palestine conflict at
long we needed somebody to solve it we
need to get him over to Joe Biden we
need to get him on the next can't do it
to Jerusalem
Theus here he
is I this will sound really bad Israel
in Egypt signed the US broker Camp David
Accords shortly after that Israel get
sign a this this is a really bad
question chat why don't they just I this
will sound really bad take the whole
piece of land full reset all the same
and just call it like like landia like
it's just land like [__] it and it's
everybody wins okay so is he
serious I mean yeah just put every some
place under
call absolutely serious I watch a little
bit more wow no uh he's definitely
serious I'm sorry he thinks that people
are mad about the
name they don't care about the land they
just want the [__] name straight yeah
they hate the name I don't think that's
why they're fighting bro I actually I
found a photo of what landia would look
like I think it's both I think he
thinks oh good this is
yeah I think he thinks once it's all
combined it will need a new name so he
came up with l so he says he says full
hold on let me I'm gon to watch it again
because I feel
like maybe we're missing his eye level
ideas in Egypt signed the US broker Camp
David Accords shortly after that Israel
gave sign a this is this is a really bad
question chat why don't they just this
will sound really bad this is going to
sound really bad sound really dumb I
don't know but bad it's like the whole
piece of land full reset all the same
and just call it like like a landia so
he so he's a one
state
yeah he's a one state solution
guy that is a radical uh idea um excc
but uh I appreciate you standing by your
convictions a one state
solution very good very good maybe I'll
have him on to debate me next about the
Israel
Palestine
um oh speaking of um Israel Palestine
getting resolved another high level idea
is being exchanged by Aiden Ross and I
show speed about the yeah yes so so far
from the twitch uh think tanks we have
landia and we have this is the kick uh
Think Tank actually the okay so I guess
speed is Palestine and um Aiden Ross
being Jewish he's uh he's with the
Israelis and here they're hashing it out
Israel I thought it was free
Palestine well you know speed I'm Jewish
so I'm from Israel really well my
descent is Israel I'm Jewish free pal so
so I genuinely think Ross thinks that
all Jewish people are descended from
Israel yeah I guess theoretically if you
go back far you go back far enough we I
guess I don't but like I don't know that
it would be Israel in those
from there too I
guess I mean if he did An ancestry test
what it say we're all from central
Africa in a way true yeah I mean listen
at the end of the day we're all Prim
primordial uh
soup we're all single cell organisms at
the end of the
day
Aiden speed we're not going to go into
that political debate
but relax is this not a is is this not a
bit this is like a so weird with the
music I think there could be a study on
this because I'm 99% sure these people
wasn't that stupid when they started
streaming I think no I think they become
what they play after a while I think
they devolve into this weird state of uh
mental like a mental state where it's
just streamer yeah because their
stupidity is being encouraged every day
that's why yeah it's like day after day
after day I think they just become this
person start and I'm that's why excus is
like that I think he just devolved into
that it's like a reverse Evolution yes
that doesn't sound like a good Sy you
know NFL players they're getting their
brains rattled CTE or whatever twitch
streamers are really on The Cutting Edge
of this [__] too they need to be studied
they're they're
devolving they're walking backwards in
The
evolutionary uh chain there relax wait
so you're
from wait so wait you're from so you you
don't even look from Israel though I'm
Jewish
Raiden's confusing everybody now like
his fans are young dudes and I show
speed is actually the one who's right
what does that have to do with being
correct to be confused but now I think
everyone in chat cuz I don't I don't
suspect people are watching this have
any idea really about this stuff and
there's just so much confusion H
springing from this video people is not
from Israel right yes we are we are
really is that true
y'all yes yes I'm Jewish I'm I do you
know what Birthright is or
no have to do with anything what is this
conversation I love the dramatic music
so much what is that no no no Birthright
is when um a Jewish person has a free
trip to go to what that have
to all that stuff it's it's it's it's um
it's the culture the religion yes so
that means you're
Jewish how is that related to being is
I think I guess he thinks because
because he could go on btri he is he's
from Israel therefore yeah my family is
from there bro he thinks that means he's
born there I was born in Israel yeah I
have birth it's his right to have been
birthed there true that's how he thought
about it true what why don't you go to
why don't you go to
Israel me go to Israel do you I don't
bro is it safe over there
yeah
it oh yeah bro I go bro I'll go bro I'll
go bad there some bad Israeli and
[__] really and they don't got
dicks that that part I didn't understand
what transphobia yeah just a little
sprinkle on there bad is really BW and
they ain't got no dick neither yeah damn
Aiden's such a [__] disaster of a
human being dud the face is so funny too
it's like doing that Al sh like he's
like his goofy smile it's just like
resting place it's very
scary like why you saying that like I I
mean it doesn't really matter but like
why you saying that though bro dude
speed is kind of the mature one he's
like why' you say that maybe I can I
show speed dud I show class I show class
Aiden is the only one that can make I
show speed look like The Classy smart
one there was another clip where he
almost did like a gang sign thing where
that would have got him killed and like
showed feet jumped up and like stopped
him like yo yo don't do that [__] but he
yeah it would have been bad Aiden
understands the street he knows what
he's doing he's cool like that yeah like
what like damn bro but y but yeah a rap
bro Arab girls are so pretty bro so
they're they're gorgeous right yeah a
high level conversation going on really
you know the music really adds to it
like existential music
you're right love about the de Evolution
yeah happening in front of us this is a
funny comment this is my leftovers
number
61 we're
back we are back nice we are so
back here's isow speed saving Aiden's
life apparently yeah I show speed just
saved Aiden Ross's
life was on stream with en choa and his
cre they had a secret handshake and
Aiden wanted to do it but luckily speed
knew what that meant and he stepped
in come on that's the only way that get
the Vibes back up it's down right
now maybe we can't watch this this the
song's over okay no more music please
bro please bro
please I'm begging you just do
it what is he on his knees bro please
bro
[__] 100% never do that no more
never
never n you got to do one of these
Detroit that looks so cool no no
no [__] he's
serious my God now when you get ready
you do okay spe's A real one for that
actually he saved his ass God that was
that was pretty pretty I show class I
show Intelligence I show the world how
it's done
mhm that's my guy right
there I hope his lungs are
okay you hope you wish his what's okay
his lungs are okay did we did we show
that on the show or did we just talk
about it behind the from the fireworks
and stuff no he set off some like
chemical reaction in his bedroom the
elephant yeah like the elephant thing or
whatever and like they did it wrong and
the room just like instantly filled with
fumes and then he was like almost
throwing up from the coughing he was
allegedly also brought to the hospital
according to his friend crazy I feel
like that's his dick though at this
point uh let's
see Dark Day for blue check conspiracy
accounts this is interesting what do you
guys think of this as you know uh there
was a new monetization program put in
place on X Twitter I
mean
uh and people get paid in not a tweet so
Elon tweeted this out making a slight
change to Creator monetization any posts
that are corrected by Community notes
becomes ineligible for Revenue share the
idea is to maximize the incentive for
accuracy over sensationalism yo this is
going to be
War because you can Brigade Community
notes yeah I feel like they're on
everything it basically just means like
we're not going to do it anymore yeah
Bas yeah basically I mean who's not
going to get a Community note
right you know you could say the sky is
blue and they'll note it and be like
well actually it's not literally blue
it's just uh different chem uh
wavelength of different atoms I thought
they need money how are they now going
to afford paying people to tweet exactly
makes no sense yeah here's what happened
really they paid a bunch of people at
first a ton of money to make it look
awesome and also you need to be signed
up yeah for their
$5 a month [__] to be eligible for
the monetization that's literally a
Ponzi scheme like yes you need you need
to pay me so that you can make money
that is that is never not a scam yep and
so now I saw people tweeting like dude I
made $8 this month from like 20 million
impressions or something you know I I
there that's the next link down oh good
so God you have to be such a [__] to
pay for that sorry
if you have paid if you're in this room
and you paid for
it I was trying to think of an Anakin
line ob1 but I couldn't think of
anything like half the people in here so
this dude said I had 16 million
pressions this month he got 17
bucks wow well it covered his it covered
his um you know and then read the next
the reply and the reply under that it's
based off The Impressions generated by
other users who are also verified wait
what yeah so speaking of your Ponzi
scheme uh contion so you only get paid
for people who pay and watch pay for pay
what but then but then you just have
this closed ecosystem of people just
paying each other pointlessly you're not
sharing the ad Revenue at all because
there are no
ads they running a scam what dude what
they was giving out people 20K and ran
out of money for sure here's another
person you got 14 bucks this dude said
2.6 million impressions and his check
was 11 I mean listen that's not a lot of
Impressions because impressions are wild
over that is that's actually kind of
okay right cuz that's like a tweet yeah
if you're a juicer yeah yeah they I they
shouldn't look at Impressions tell me
how many I think the yeah likes or
retweets or something I don't know
because it's supposed to be off of the
ads that are placed on so Impressions
block I forgot I had face paint and just
put
my my beard in my
mouth like
a god you look so [__] crazy you got
a black line on your tooth I do uh it's
cleaning
off and that's it yeah don't you think
there' be a cool version of Joker where
he does this ft paint face paint instead
that'd be
sick the teeth look so good the dot
evaporated yeah they they got
smudged I am I am square SpongeBob
square true you know and you do have
holes Square
this is an insane the Jersey Lawman new
edit about Catch a Predator do you know
the Jersey
Lawman no I only know one Jersey Outlaw
so there's a spin-off of the Jersey
Outlaw the Jersey Lawman we don't know
who he is but he was a ton of effort
into editing these absolutely insane
parodies he's incredible of Jimmy Lee
okay God damn it
um keep ticking out my [__] closing
the browser
close the TRU and it there's people
really don't follow his Antics either I
mean this post has
like yeah it's this one has 300 likes
but he keeps going you know he's
dedicated It's About Love of the Game
for
him so here's the Jersey lawmen a new
edit this has 400 likes Queen is just
around the corner and okay hold on
it's Friday night in downtown Los
Angeles Halloween is just around the
corner and this guy is about to fart in
a Denny's
restaurant he says he graduated from the
University of California Santa Cruz with
a degree in English literature he worked
in the marketing industry as an
executive but he says he now hosts an
online video podcast M it's not long
before Klein contacts our decoy we'll
call him James and the chat gets a
little runchy do you guys still serve
the All-American Grand black LOL y it's
been on the menu forever I really want
to destroy some blank shakes and ice
cream too is the ice cream machine
working today LOL yeah it's in service
right now Quin knows he's already late
for work and he says he knows what he's
doing is wrong as a 42-year-old married
guy I shouldn't be eating alone at
Denny's like this you know how
embarrassing it would be for me to get
caught by a foa trooper a name given to
Kin by his fans based on a popular
character from Super
Mario it's Friday night so first it
needs to be said that none of this
happened this is all fictionary really
how it needs to be said it seems real to
me you seem pretty confident on the
internet okay did was that AI Voice or
did he get a Fiverr person to do that it
was AI for yeah dude AI voice people are
going to ruin Fiverr economy the LA man
does a lot of incredible AI voices dude
the meme economy is doing so great after
AI the actual economy is crumbling
though [__] that though [__] him um we
like I like videos of people falling off
stage I enjoy those in general and
here's a good new one Shakira's
x what just shakir's X like what kind of
moniker is that he Gerard Peak is that
he's the one who cheated on her remember
H oh with the jam oh that was the drunk
episode you were very drunk when we when
we learned about that but she found a
jam in their fridge when she came home
right oh yeah yeah I don't remember that
oh well the girl who he cheated on
Shakira with actually cheated on him
with his soccer coach
whoa I don't know if they mended things
but that did happen crazy all right well
so here's this idiot falling off stage
and it's just a good
time he a
[Music]
dummy just disappeared and nobody cares
either and it's what he
deserves just a fun little thing you
know nothing
crazy just something to share with the
people at
home uh let's
see okay I guess we should do the Mike
Myers thing now and then we can do this
Jack dhy bodyguard punch story which is
a great story MH phenomenal story David
do had a Halloween party sponsored by
the way by feat
finder which is a website where you know
it's like only fans for feet I've heard
about dudes going on that and like
manicuring their feet and making their
toes look all cute and then they're
selling them as women's feet to bunch of
morons really yeah yeah that's a hustler
right that's a hustle hell yeah I have I
feel like I could do that maybe don't
you think let's try it I mean yeah wish
is that unethical no [__] as to see who
could sell Fe their Fe picks faster as
long as we never let them know you know
if they get to know and they realize
what's been going on that would suck Ian
is that a good idea or is it
unethical Ian is not here
bad yeah it's we'll do a contest to see
who can sell them fastest oh like
anonymously yeah well we'll show it on
the show but on the platform will be
anonymous yeah I see I see that would
that would destroy the Integrity of the
test sure would it's kind of crazy but
it's also pretty
funny to just see who who has the most
attractive feet or you dll them up and
Market them as like women's
feet oh I
see get them in hair and makeup well
maybe maybe men's feet sell too you
could however you want to approach it
right right right you know I have a
feeling there's a bigger market for
women's feet just based on the wiki feet
uh Saga we paed yeah I think that's
probably fair but I do think who would
be down to participate in this
Gauntlet other than me me love AB yeah
Zach yeah I'll do it
Dan I think Ian would do it yo this is
great
okay this is great I love this good
times that's fun we have to make a note
of can you make a note you want to like
try to doll it up you could get a
professional that's what I want yeah my
feet are going to look so good mine's
going to be nasty I mean we kind of like
we sort of did this although I guess
those were more jokey you're talking
like actually trying to make them look
selling I want someone to pay me for
pictures of my feet got it got it got it
by the way you guys were laughing about
my Joker analogy but this looksy it
looks really
good I mean yeah he
scary pretty good mustard yellow is
terrifying okay so basically uh I don't
know is the food what should we do I
guess we should do the Michael
Myers yeah sure I mean it's going to
take a while is the food here I don't
know the food is arriving right
now okay so we can do the then if you
guys want to eat we can do the Jack dhy
bodyguard punch which is great sure you
are not going to want to miss this m it
is phenomenal phenomenom
dominal
okay okay I got a pee we'll do that then
damn just I usually Can Go the whole
show with peeing once
but I'm feeling the pee I got a so bad
oh you just went Ian you can go you're
back I guess we should do the mic all
right I got to pee guys I'm sorry I'm
just going to go do that okay and then
we'll watch I'll be right back right
back right back thank
you people saying it's
scam it's
scammy Ethan saying he saw one of you
say it was
scammy someone said donate it donate the
money that we earned I mean if the
customer's happy what difference does it
make want that they're getting what they
want they get they got the feet it's an
attractive foot they can jerk off to it
or whatever the [__] people do with that
what what you doing what what are you
doing what what you doing this this is
our new favorite uh Trump sound bite
that just came out ter what what you
doing what you doing what what you doing
I love the uh indict the [__]
that one stuck in my head oh yeah that's
that's don't pay the bill for this mic
that one too
uh let me see here trying to get caught
up on these super chats a little bit
what what you doing there's a $50 one
that just says mention Sam Cedar
leaves that was for that video watch for
the video ear well thank you uh Charlie
uh Happy hello happy Halloween fellow
foot soldiers uh Megan and Matt just got
engaged this weekend congrats to them
family family family con
congratulations I assume that's one of
you
no maybe not I'm not sure um been
subscribed for years only recently
became a member I love you guys so much
and I love teddy fresh you are in the
right place Maddie you're in the right
place uh $20 donation Ethan and Ela this
is my last attempt at getting this
artwork to you guys it's my profile
picture and Ela posted on her story a
few weeks back please let me know how to
send it over peace and love
uh let me let me see this I'm blowing
out my voice talking to this stupid the
worst ever
had but well it sounds like they already
saw it right specific it sounds like
maybe they don't want
it yeah w i mean wa they said they've
been made a bunch of attempts and I
can't stand Dan damn let being with you
I don't know uh the blasphemy put some
uh
respect on these Legends Jason fought
Freddy yes right it was Jason versus
Freddy I don't think Michael Myers has
crossed over with them Freddy Krueger is
the scariest uh Friday the 13th is the
best of all those old slasher movies in
my opinion I'd agree but I think
Freddy's the scariest because that
[__] can go into your dreams yeah
that's that's Freddy you just said Jason
I said Friday the 13th Friday the 13th's
not Freddy am I getting him confused
Jason's Friday the 13th Freddy's
Nightmare on nightmare El oh Nightmare
on Elm Street you're right you're right
my bad well Nightmare on Elm Street is
the one that I met you know there
there's a lake in uh Michigan with a a
statue of Jason in it it's um someone
put it there it's [__] horrifying as
[__] under water yeah underwater I have
to check it out next time I go seems
dangerous cuz Camp Chris Camp Crystal
Lake was the uh the place where he uh
drowned at was that in Michigan does it
take place I don't know I maybe in the
movie I don't know if it is in real life
when I was a kid it was always Child's
Play that scared the [__] out of me cuz
I'm like dude my Power Rangers are going
to [__] jump me in my sleep see
Chucky never did it like I always
thought I could kick this doll's ass you
know it's a [__] doll yeah seems like
people just a [__] doll [__]
finging I mean like
SC and and then he gets like Chucky was
a murderer what was his name like
Charles Lee Ray or something like that
and then he like transforms into the the
good boy doll or whatever the [__] it's
called
mhm I mean I I think the concept of
being killed by your toys always scared
the [__] out of me even Goosebumps like
the Slappy episodes as that when I was a
kid Slappy Slappy was pretty [__]
scary but yeah Chucky had kick it ass
okay so um I'm back you're back thank
you everybody all so let's talk about
this Jack dorsy thing
there um this dude jack it off I've seen
him
around you know in videos with kind of
the usual dumbass
suspects uh he's a tick
tocker um and his stick I guess is just
annoying people or like being a
douche which is like I guess that's a
lot people shtick these days they're
like I'm a douche and that's my
compelling uh that's what's compelling
about
me uh you guys will probably recognize
him some of you might here this
kid he I don't know how old I I got to
temper my my words a bit does look
pretty young he is very young how old is
he uh he was born in
2003 um 16 is the age of consent 20 okay
yeah he's not that
young he he's young though
yeah um he's also a
douche but you could say that okay hold
on so here's his page he got 10 million
followers 9.3 million
followers um let's take a look at what
his content is like here this one is
for oh he post wait wait it only has
420,000 I bet it's been reposted a bunch
of times right so his views are kind of
low here like bro who's watching your
[__] yeah this is he probably fell off
he was way B figure wait this dude fell
off like colossally like dude nobody's
watching okay hold on here's one get
that out of my face get out of my face
or what
[Music]
[Applause]
okay oh also by the
way this dude goes around acts like a
giant douche and then has massive
security guard so nobody can mess with
him like he's doing the Jimmy Lee kind
of but it's like dude come on on bro
you're so lame shoot the son of a
[__]
Jesus yeah so um one of his bodyguards
actually committed a attempted murder in
my opinion at this David Do's party fact
I don't even know can we show
it it
uh it didn't get uh age restricted when
I reup it still green
yeah it appears that way it's it's
pretty violent yeah I mean the guy gets
up immediately he's not bleeding or
anything that's true like he got up
immediately he did which is very
impressive When You See It honestly as
impressive as the punch right was the
way he bounced back so here's this
little douchy he's at David Do's party
he's trying to
um he's trying to talk to uh Karina
cough Karina Karina
and so oh God this has 74 million views
so here's this
video you think so the first response
was um God I bet Jack didn't want this
video to get out cuz it makes him like
um liable it's like a huge liability um
but then we realized no he's the one
that posted
it he said my security guard just
knocked out a guy live on my
kick so wait then how am I supposed to I
got I kind of got to show it don't
I I mean you could he got punched and
he's
fine so this guy's his security guard
the massive dude I'm just saying y'all
say walk don't walk
oh
F it's I've seen it so many times that
it doesn't shock me that's why I laugh
cuz it's like so [__] insane but like
the dude was so
not being physically uh aggressive not
at all and this man just he tried to
kill him I mean I don't know talking I'm
just saying y'
say captain Ino show no mercy dude but
then like we said he bounces up like
this dude's made of rubber this
dude's he's about to be king of the
pirates with that
elasticity but the punch was really I've
I don't think I've ever seen a punch
like that look at that his glasses go
flying people like that are scary who
just are big and can't stop themselves
from hitting someone well he certainly
be shouldn't be in security right that's
what I was about to say like that
[__] he can kill people with
that kind of rage and
so scary dude I don't know how this dude
he literally the force of it knocked him
down look at that look at
that that's a kadab my friends that is a
mean hit but then he bounces right back
up and he's fine which is
nuts no stop stop what is wrong with you
are you [__] crazy what's up hey by
one what's up [__] security guard are
you [__] you [__]
dude super uh super professional guy you
got here Jack oh yeah [__] you [__]
Jesus well done [__] my face
[__] [__]
[__] and then
Jack [__] posted
this that's crazy to me that's a crime
right I mean that that's just a
crime that's just straight up
assault maybe even worse than assault
cuz he's so big you know yeah
so
um here he is again filming a
girl at David's
party um wasted girl with no consent
should I should I show this is it bad
form to show it
like you don't see her much do you it's
on the
subreddit I
mean I wish Dan wasn't in the
bathroom I watch it but if it shows her
face too much we can button it out we
can bail yeah hey follow me on Kick guys
it's been a stream so far D yo hey are
you good no okay shut the [__]
up you taking content are you taking
content we're taking content oh my God
shut the [__] up this is my [__] she's
good hey chat what do we think about her
let's show her what you guys said you
can't really see her face
yet um he is such a little [__] boy
he's such a douche this kid he really is
you fig to feed her some water cuz why
are you taking contct with
friends hey yo watch this what're saying
why would you
what why would you do this just leave
them alone man
it's content Brin I guess but but even
then oh my God that's so cute stop stop
look watch I don't care what they're
saying thank you thank you thank
you why are you live streaming this
you're an [__] go away am I yes how
are you are you 19 go away I'm 20 you're
I'm giving her my water why are you
[__] taking why you taking I'm for
the
moments before tragedy look at his by
the way his guard is
super oh yeah he's super
engaged
mhm go away I just want to look good now
after that and I'm kidding [__] you
[__] [__] hell [__] first thing
she said to me Shut the [__] I'm 12
you're [__] [__] hey I don't give a
[__] God he's so annoying why does this
man enjoy any measure of success is
truly
astounding and this again it's could be
in perceived as inspiring and
that
um anyone can make it right and that's
my fear with people like I show speed
when he's in every news article dexerto
every single day has something else
about him these kids are like oh I could
do that I could light up a firework in
my room I could call a girl a [__] at a
party that's true it and he does did I
not get a
chicken
no I don't have it no I just got French
fries it's you guys cry go oh no no no
the fact that's happening at David Do's
Halloween party sponsored by feet finder
makes it all the
better you he my feelings it's just
don't film somebody when she dress
that's just I don't see that the next
day and be like embarrassed you know
like that's all how many of y'all going
to say the same [__] thing huh no I'm
kidding
because you guys all want to pitch in
cuz you're girls and you guys don't know
what to do besides being
drama what have a good
day I I get like the whole like thing
but just like they want to end up on a
good note hey have a good
night get right and then I think right
after this
ho God imagine being this embarrassing
he's got like a streaming setup some
dude fall him with a camera and a
massive bodyguard
[Music]
mhm and then to a party right to a party
and Halloween party not wearing a
costume by the way when he when he getss
that's true what a [__] and then when
he gets out of line at the party and
people are telling him off not
threatening him at all his bodyguard
commits a violent vicious assault and
then he tweets it out
yeah
good
guy we love him um yeah
his his video was sponsored by feat
finder which started my oh yeah
feetfinder this whole thing look David's
Halloween Town Halloween Town presented
by
feetfinder how much did feed finder pay
for this [__]
party I mean I don't know question
I can't imagine that it was a good
investment although I'm talking about it
yeah why don't I never get [__] paid
dude well we got to hit feed finder up
[__] say what we got to hit feed finder
up yeah let's Reach Out feed finder
where's where are you
guys it's so unfair how all these guys
get deals I have a interesting
categories on the website go ahead high
heels SES nail polish socks lotion
pedicure Dirty Feet nail awesome dancer
tattoo showing face nylon yo showing
face hold on uh ASMR Arch Asian
BBW
dominatrix any um Barefoot Brothers
smelly driving
um are you seeing um what gender are you
seeing uh predominantly
female
but you do see some there was a male
category okay okay it's not popping over
there food it's it's a ghost town mature
you want some mature feet
oh
uh need them wrinkly toes [__] nuts
dude thank
you
cool um stomping I'm going to mail let's
see what the most popular sponsor us for
us two un uncle is a category Uncle wait
what does that mean what Uncle oh is
that when you have to say uncle like
it's a it's like a wrestling uh or just
like incest fantasy C it I it's
loading
um hey that's my uncle no it's just it's
men's feet I think it's supposed to be
like your uncle's feet what what doesn't
make sense it's a very specific knee
shirt uncle UNC why specifically
Uncle what makes it Uncle feet really
defines BR it's a Vibe I don't know is
Uncle a specific
fantasy I I mean yeah [__] your uncle
uncle [__] that's the first time ever
hearing about that I mean right that's
[__] your [__] uncle [__] your
[__] face Uncle so there's an uncle
but there's not like a like a
daddy I feel like that would make more
sense female Gra graer oh that's
fire that's grappling I like that email
Grappler yeah this when they wrestle bro
okay duh dance you know anything like
foot wrestling I suppose no no this goes
beyond feet this is like the face
category you this is feet finder dude
it's Bed Bath and Beyond Feer
Beyond and there's a category called
jugs jugs what wait look at
knockers there's everything on here you
got to see the you got to see the icon
for The Stomping category here
here oh step on me Mom dude that's so
[__] aw giant that's my
fantasy uh pedal pumping oh yeah oh
that's
see oh that's dude true
refunder you think he's on here no you
think he knows about this site if
there's a everywhere hold on he made the
website if there's a community anywhere
on the internet about feat he's involved
yo you're so right
dude I can pull these up this isn't this
isn't very explicit let me make sure oh
wait yeah don't maybe don't pull the
website up because yeah I'm not I'm
trying to screenshot but um in the
pedal
category 12 toes there it is it's
barefoot driving
oh see I didn't know if this there's a
bunch of them wow so there's so the
women are up to the up to it as well
yeah these are Barefoot sisters driving
but close enough 12 toes is a category
six toes is a
category hold on that's not real though
right that's like fake I can't I think I
think there's a relatively common uh
there's that many people with 12 Toes
that they have a category for it prob
have a high price
let's see what is it called you got to
pay extra for that toast
polydactyl polya one in 3,000 this is
weird one in 3,000 mhm okay so I mean
it's not too bad I think that means
there be
like what would that mean there's like
30,000 people in the US I'm seeing
conflicting though actually the next few
websites did 500 to 1ou uh 1,000 I'm
sorry one out of every 500 to 1,000 so I
don't really know H maybe like 1 to 750
needs further study I suppose that means
someone at your school is walking around
right now with six goddamn toes on their
feet I knew someone Elementary School at
nine or on one foot they had four on one
foot five on the other R they'll be in
the sales section of the website so they
just have an extra yeah you get a 20%
discount miss one all right so that's it
I I thought there's more to it but
there's not really he's just a little
punk ass
[__] let me look at his Tik Tok see if
there's anything good
there I can't breathe when I'm out
you I can't sleep when I'm out
to um okay wait here's another Tik Tok
do Jack
Dy this can't be him too is it no 700 no
there a CH no
reuploads you know when you do a Google
search now it comes up Tik toks comes up
as a category I saw like next to videos
it said Tik toks I really I don't know
if it was like only on a certain browser
but that could be useful here he is uh 2
million on excuse me whatever you guys
say in 3 seconds I'll buy for you
whistle no shoes shoes yeah oh God it's
this [__] guy oh [__] this girka guy
who's just a he is so vile man he's
disgusting he got in a fight over the
weekend too on stream all these kick
streamers every every single day there's
a new person getting jumped or fighting
dude fighting is sick bro that's what
Alphas do real men throw down and throw
punches we just have too much
testosterone bro I can't help
it my dick is always hard especially
when I
fight want
grappling what's your name is this your
boyfriend why are you so close to her
jeez
okay how old are you 29 all right let's
going dude really is wearing the
smallest pants in the world
somebody told us this was the popular
look right that the the Bros now are
wearing tiny short shorts that's the Bro
Look to show off their fat their [__]
thighs bro you know and they are juicy
you so close to look how are how balls
are about to come out for real bro I
think it's his shirt too he's wearing
like an Exel shirt with it that makes it
look even smaller it's a dress shirt a
combination I I mean Forever 21 Vibes I
can't help but feel like what she's
wearing looks like underwear dude what
she's wearing is a whole another thing
29 all right let's go in here I don't
why is it so tight I've never
seen right cut that joke out all right
so what do you want shoes yeah yeah what
okay so I don't I don't know man this is
bad content you
I this is the video with views and
you're I can't even see you in
it that's why the less you the better it
turns out
um that's that Jack dhy everybody still
confused about how he got so popular
because I'm scrolling down significantly
and I still not seeing he got famous
when he was super
young oh oh like way way way back yeah
like two years
ago ancient history I'm seeing pranks
every time I'm seeing pranks and
challenges there's clips of him being
like 15 saying he bought a house and
[__] like that he used to flex when he
was a kid that t typical like rice Gump
I'll tell you this Jack I hope you I
hope you uh got a fixed mortgage and not
a variable one
cuz times are going to be so true things
are going to be so tough for you so true
that's just good advice yeah click off
for a sec I want to see what his website
is
off how to make money sick how I make
money learn how I made $10 million on
social media and 19 no [__] shot this
dude made $1 million
no shot but I want to
learn and the link doesn't work look at
this I want to
learn tell me how do I do it you guys
get paid to post my
clips and then he says he has a only
fans link and bio of Instagram oh [__]
here it is after six years getting
filthy rich on social media Jack dhy
invites you to learn his social media
Secrets borrow his viral content and get
paid look he has
three [__] cool cars dude that's sick
so let's see we got some good deals here
the you could be a early bird member for
150 oh it's almost a 70%
discount wait am I loud like are is this
a
mistake like
just seems too
low Jesus man these people are all the
same really is
incredible [__]
me oh my
God all right thank you
Jack thank you Jack jacket off all right
I guess is everyone done is everyone
ready for the uh I think we should do it
all right this is wrap it up with the
food here people do you I didn't know
yeah me
too all right so we got to do a little
bit of preparation
here all right guys it is time would you
survive a horror film or would you be
one of the idiots that gets gobbled up
by the
murderer today we will figure out who
lives and who dies
AB hereit hello is that
good Dan let me know when you're
ready I guess in the meantime as we get
set up for this I'll show the poor
Rosanna put out this
statement she just she erased everything
and
then posted this and pinned
it I would like to apologize to Mr Beast
I should have expressed my feelings
privately and handled things directly I
will be removing all the posts where I
talk about creator games in Jimmy I'll
be honest in that the thousands of death
threats I've received today are
contributing factors but I also
sincerely hear the feedback from many of
you she's too sweet for this world you
know what I mean like she stepped into
the she stepped into the eel pit yeah
yeah
which is coming
up and and you know what I mean like
it's just it's not for the faint of
heart it's not for the sweet and
wholesome yeah you have to be a demon to
get engaged with this
[__] like us
yes I was born in this [__] like
Bane so Rosanna is out she's saying
Beast is never he has never controlled
the outcome of a
video with peace and
love that's
right this was
also somebody posted this and I hadn't
seen it it's Mr Beast talking about how
he vets uh women to be his
girlfriend it's quite interesting you
you'll enjoy this
elila he was on fra flagrant uh
podcast and here it is she just stopped
by to say hi to her and like within 5
seconds I was like holy [__] this girl
is beautiful and then but I have to go
through the tests because like I don't I
don't really get along with women if
like they don't love learning they're
not obsessive they don't have a hobby
they don't like the J like there are
just certain things where if you have
these traits we get along really well
and if you don't like it's impossible
for us to hang out yeah um so I had to
put her through the ringer and start
asking questions what do you do so so
was that before cu the the whole idea of
interviewing someone before you've even
like gone on a date is very like uh um
the king takes what he wants right you
know what I mean it already feels like
he thinks he's the big prize too for the
girl that will get to date him yeah yeah
for sure oh that's that's yeah it's Mr
Beast
de YouTuber all time it's giving like
the King has sex with the
bride uh before the groom yeah and then
she was like I'm an author and I was
like [__] yeah good she has a hobby and
then we started talking she's a doctor
an author author you said author good
she has a hobby okay she has a hobby who
doesn't have a hobby like I know we
talked about this but like I guess I
don't have a hobby but I'm not trying to
[__] Mr
Beast and I just tried to get a feel of
she likes learning like you know
whatever what do you like to do sounds
cringe but you know like what kind of
content you consume and it was more like
documentary educational and like the
type of stuff she does and she has
multiple degrees you could tell she
likes learning she's about to get a
neuroscience degree just for fun not
even to get a job CU like she invested
in Bitcoin and did well so she doesn't
even like need it and she was like
checking all the boxes and I had like
these 10 things where like if I meet a
girl that's like beautiful and they have
these 10 traits like we're going to be
literally best friends checked every
single one of them was nice feet nice
feet uh no that was 11 I like I can give
on that one this is my nerdiness is
showing because like now I'm here this
is where this is where I come in oh girl
has ugly feet he said his girl has ugly
feet oh my God I'd be so mad he did say
that she's perfect except for the feet
but then that means she'd be good at
like stomping on like rotting food feet
stuff maybe like ugly feet look better
crushing ugly things
mhh like the true definition of a nerd
like I just need a partner who loves
learning you know and just wants to
improve like for us now like an idea of
a date is just to like take take an IQ
test and then study and see if we can
get a high come on bro no way bro this
so far is giving me all the wrong Vibes
like oh my God this man just said they
go on a their date is an IQ
test and
Al I feel like he seems very judgmental
already by the way he created this list
like she needs to want to learn and do
stuff because otherwise she's lazy or
something if I can be maybe uh generous
to be
I think he's a little socially uh
inept and so like if he wasn't Mr Beast
he said himself he has trouble
connecting with women I don't think he
really
understands I don't think he really
understands how to talk to women at all
and
so he's built a world where he can make
sense of it I don't know if there was
like self-awareness of that then I would
be more open to hearing it but there's
no self- awareness of anything of that
kind yeah cuz I feel like when you go
into a date or you go into like meeting
anybody you do have these lists and like
they they can't be as full-fledged as
his are it's just the way he's speaking
about it is like well before they even
went on a date he's like hold on hold on
b
word we got to do some stuff put you
through the ringer put you through the
ringer you
hear like I love it and I love watching
documentaries also this man has his feet
up on someone else's podcast that's part
of my problem like the whole body
language is not giving me like any
self-awareness of like I'm not perfect
but I will hold on don't you think
that's a little weird to put your feet
up at someone else's podcast like he
doesn't have his feet up I don't know
maybe he did at some point like we'll go
by why do he got a
laptop two books we'll read it and like
quiz each other absolute nerd I'm a
[__] nerd but that's what I needed
someone like that and it's like very
hard to find someone like that that's
also like obviously very beautiful um
yeah usually they're [__] ugly as
hell oh my God usually smart girls are
ugly as [__] I don't think he really
knows what he's saying no I'm just
trying I'm trying to I'm not trying to
become a he knows what he's saying what
does that
matter I think what I'm saying I I I
don't think he's
like I don't know Ela I'm trying I'm not
trying I don't give a [__] you're not
going to win a million bucks at this
rate yeah I wasn't going to he doesn't
give it to sweet girls like
Rosanna it's so yeah the second she like
checked all those boxes this was
probably like the like 40th the second
she checked all his boxes I went to her
and I said you will be my girlfriend
yeah I hog tied her and brought her back
to my apartment you want to or not you
will bear my children
woman different girl Beast take Beast
like women Beast
take
I had talked to since my ex and I was
just waiting till I found someone that
like met all these crer the second she
checked I was like that's it yeah wow so
then I waited a couple of days and then
I just dmed her I was like oh so your
book can I read it she sent it over read
the whole book and it was just like
acting like it was the greatest book
ever asking your questions until my God
acting what the [__] I thought you
actually cared about a small girl dude
hold on let me go back did he say that
read the whole book and it was just like
acting like it was the greatest book
ever asking your questions oh no beling
dumb [__] also like if she actually is
very accomplished and has like a book
and stuff it doesn't sound like a hobby
sounds like a i honed in on that too
that sounds like hard job I thought
about that what you do oh I'm an author
oh you have a hobby that's cute like
well I don't know if you know what I do
but that's a hobby yeah cuz you're not
making as much money as I am so like
right do you think he's like in the
presence of like these manly men and he
feels like he has to like he's trying to
fit in maybe yeah 100% cuz you can tell
the way he's speaking out about her is
Mr Beast you either got it all or not
right he gets to have it his way I think
they should be kissing his [__]
feet the guys and be trying to fit in
with him like I'm a dork yeah I'm same
way I'm the should give money I love
learning I'm the ner she me wait he
really just said this she sent it over
read the whole book and it was just like
acting like it was the greatest book
ever asking bro why did you say that
that's so
mean I totally think he's trying to
match their kind of energy cuz he's not
usually this blatant it's weird but when
have you seen him recently do an
interview I guess so but I'm not going
to give him any for me personally it's
been a couple years since he was on our
podcast that's true yeah and he's been
quite a lot more successful and
definitely something gotone to his head
when he was on our podcast he was like
uh oh wow I was expecting better
questions or something for me you
remember that he's like oh I always get
asked the same questions I'm like bro
you're a YouTuber what the [__] man he
didn't put his feet on the table though
at least you say you say Jake Paul 3,000
times remember that was like his content
in the beginning it was Innovative I
mean it got him attention right mhm I've
heard him talk about that book in a
different interview and his energy was
completely different about the book yeah
like he seemed to think it was really
cool and I don't know maybe he is kind
of matching their energy he's just he
wants he's browing out with the alph
trying to brow out he's like yo so my
girlfriend she write a book and she sent
me that [__] and I was like this shit's
[__] sucks but I pretended like I
liked it everyone's like yo high five
girls are
dumb girls
suck your questions until we hung out
again
okay yeah and then you officially ask
her you go do you want to be my
girlfriend or you guys just talk about
well that's where it's weird because
she's in South Africa just like a
30-hour flight away she can't come to
America cuz she doesn't have a Visa so
like dude you're Mr Beast pull some
strings man you got to know a couple
Senators by now you know this is how you
know I'm into her cuz I like a 30-hour
flight there and a 30 hour flight back
to go hang okay there's no [__] way
it's a 30 hour flight one way that's
impossible no I think that's true
probably true no way pretty of course
from SW 30 hours no shot it's 15 15 yeah
yeah that's double that dude I think if
you got a swap plane maybe not a
straight shot probably hours or more
with Google
search something and it's 20 yeah it
says anywhere between 10 to 20 yeah I
mean 20 22 maybe makes more sense 30
hours that's like a over a whole day
possibly we lay over or something I
think it must be with a layover or
something well she she would maybe he's
in a private plane cuz private planes
are actually pretty slow oh if he's if
he's going private AFA he probably would
he's probably making like three videos
on the way to so making a few stops true
cuz I like a 30 hour flight there and a
30 hour flight back where does he live
Ohio or some [__] uh Carolina or
something Carolina do Carolina to Cape
Town or whatever yeah it's like it's
like closer to 20 hours okay I mean but
that's without layovers
probably or is that yeah okay all right
cuz sometimes when I when I flew here I
had one stop but I got to wait four hour
4 hours but Beast doesn't lay over ex
exactly but yeah his time is more
important maybe he's like that sheep he
just takes his sheep he's not cheap no
you don't think so no he's not
cheap to go hang yeah so I just fly out
there to hang out with her and show that
like I'm a real human cuz I I want to do
the Mike Mars but this is fascinating me
this is so fascinating I'll just watch
it a little bit longer I'm just I'm
really into it and he keeps just until
he stops talking about
it 20 30 minutes at dinner and then I
instantly look at the title the
clickbait title how Mr Beast met his new
girlfriend not the old loser one we got
a new
girlfriend shiny smells good fresh car
smell they flew back cuz Antarctica
shoots cancelled yeah so it's like it
was it was a little weird at first cuz
it's not like oh let's just hang out
it's like hey can I spend 30 hours on a
plane to see you and then I instantly
have to spend 30 hours the next day to
fly back because I have a company to run
and just flying there takes three entire
days off plane [__] oh up okay he's he
keeps increasing it now we're at three
days three days what
the 6 months to go see
her so and like the Visa oh this is
where it gets in interesting uh to get a
Visa they're like oh it'll take two
years like even like a tourist visa yeah
same with India to here yeah it's it's
that's actually not true well maybe
maybe from South afri she's not like a
work visa right too I'm sorry I'm so
curious if there's more context as to
why he's sitting like this like it
started some go to the podcast and scan
back I yeah dude if he it's crazy if he
did that like unprompted right it's like
you know they said Napoleon was the
first person then at KNE when he took
the crown he stood up that's that's the
is giving me yeah this is my podcast now
right well I think that was just cuz he
was so short oh
maybe he didn't need if he kneeled then
I've always heard in like a badass way
though no I'm kidding but I heard he
swam through the yeah he swam she swam
to back to France oh
yeah brutal but one thing that's
interesting is if you when people can so
it's a website you see all the dates
it'll be like the first date's 8 months
down the road well when people cancel
it's first come first serve and so when
we found that out so like we we had her
appointment like8 or 9 months out but
when someone canceled 6 months out we
just paid someone to sit there and
refresh and then book it for when it
came out so like someone would cancel 6
months out ours [__] ours now it's
like so it's like great all right so he
so Mr be says he pays someone to sit on
the Visa website and refresh it all day
MH that's
psycho that's
crazy such a weird Flex it's such a
beast thing though who else would do
that all right your job is to sit here
I'm you you're in shifts three shifts
eight hours just refresh refresh refresh
refresh now I get her in six months
[__] perfect [__] flying over there
and then like two days ago like we just
yeah we we just hired this uh person to
do it and that's all they did all day
just refresh that page and then we get
it four months out I'm like [__] yeah
this is great so 6 months wasn't enough
they got to keep here's something that's
interesting like I know this guy uh
what's his
name the guy the host of the Andrew
Schultz Andrew Schultz is like this I
don't take no [__] from nobody and I
call it like I see it kind of guy and
here they are listening to the [__]
craziest rambling and laughing and and
giggling like what they're hearing is
rational it's so bizarre like at least
say it's so bizarre you know that's
weird
mhm yeah to fly 30 hours for one dinner
and then go back is a little weird not
even that it's
the the uh uh everything yeah the
interview
process like for really he started the
podcast with his feet up it started with
one foot up on the table that's that's
that's really intense oh my God I feel
like I just got to speak up I don't
think it's a big deal at all did he put
his feet on the table cares kick back
he's relaxed you would I feel like he
looks awesome like that sting like I
know why you're running in on that I
just I've been holding my tongue but I
don't think it's a big deal that he has
I think it's much weirder that he's
talking about doing an IQ test for first
date no it's all weird it's all weird
the full package but to me it's giving a
little bit like he comes in like I own
this [__] place this is my
place I'm trying to look cool I don't
know am I the only one that thinks the
feed up is kind of uh no no it sounded
it sounds like it's a mixed bag I think
I'm an outlier here maybe Middle Eastern
background I don't know if I have my
foot on the table it's going to chopped
off like you don't [__] around that
listen if I'm at your house or in your
studio you put your [__] feet up but
what is that piece of furniture for for
isn't that it's a table it's not a foot
stool so with Dan like he's just you
know being comfortable chilling dude
he's just chill wow so there's
differences in opinion even between the
two of you guys this tearing us
apart is real Gaza all over
again I'm going to put my feet on Lena's
parents table and see what they say it's
different it's not like this is in a
middle eastern home yeah it's a podast
with with your boys you know you put
your feet up I just don't think it's
okay but you're telling me like when is
it acceptable to put your feet up when
you're with the boys at least if the
host was doing it it's like giving you a
ke follow the lead this is this is on
table here in this room to do something
like that you know what you you don't
know who it's tearing the community part
right now too everybody's arguing about
it P pull it up to me it there it does
it is disrespectful because he's coming
into someone else's space who is just
met like you don't know the person
you're sitting with what if they're like
they don't like germs they don't wear
your dirty shoes on the table it could
be like they completely don't care but
you don't even know them and also you
got to be aware of who you are like
you're the biggest YouTuber in the world
like I don't know a little bit more
selfawareness self- awareness yeah I
guess to not do that like clearly people
are going to say you think you're the
[__] you think you're this you're like
I'm going to put my hands up and my
[__] feet on the table well you know
what yeah what do you guys want if I was
the maybe maybe I would put my feet on
the table and my hands behind my head
like who knows I think that maybe I
would think that made me look
awesome you're telling me what's the
name of this comedian again flagrant guy
Andrew Schultz you're telling me Andrew
Schultz just listen to someone say that
their first date they do a IQ test
together and he didn't have anything to
say about that come on now all day just
refresh that page and then we get it
four months out I'm like [__] you this
great 3 months every day I'm waking up
and it's getting a little shorter and
then it's like a that potentially is
illegal by the way I feel
like legal yeah I mean this is a legal
process I don't think I don't think
you're just taking available spots from
from people who he's like Leafly leaping
over
immigrants money falling out of his
pockets yeah it's kind of [__] up but
I don't
know [__] dude and let's not forget the
anti-Semitism of wearing Yeezys no I'm
kidding true I'm kid wow true well said
that's a joke I I have too many Yeezys
that I haven't had the heart to let go
of so listen you already own it right
true but it's it's not easy wearing
Yeezys out there I'll tell it's not it's
not like it was right Ian they're not
really I got all really did you sell
them yes I did wow that's that is
actually really interesting to know
what's the resale value on those
like uh I sold a pair I think I got like
90 bucks what's the
MSRP uh 200 maybe okay that's not bad to
be honest for used shoes I mean [__]
yeah Zach is the the sneaker head I'm
curious what he
thinks you judge someone for wearing
Yeezys
Zach it looks like he he's maybe
thinking that he does J
no all right thank you
Zach like no cancellations no nothing
I'm like God damn it I still gotta wait
three months that means I got to fly to
South Africa like four times you hire
her and sponsor a Visa copywriter I
don't know all that [__] takes time um
but this this is
the dude he owns this [__] place look
totally get what's on the table is it
also food alcohol it's
food it's alcohol that's that's not time
to put shoes on the table when there's
food on the table true true
solution
know qualifies his food oh he made him
eat Beast Burgers these dudes sat across
from him smiled in his [__] a face
and and said M this Beast Burger is
good come on now not at all
raw I guess this was after he had a
dramatic breaking with his partner
because the quality control was so
atrocious people are getting rawood
SC honestly the ghost kitchen phenomenon
I blame on Mr
be he popularize it yeah dude and I hate
the ghost kitchens it's just so
lame she starts giving you attitude on
the phone you're like eight months
oop but then then we uh then I wake up
one day from like
20 I don't know why they're I don't know
what they're laughing about they're just
Bing him up it's bizar I didn't know
what they're laughing about what was
funny I want to be in on the joke I want
to laugh too I like to
laugh shut up D all right there it is
all right let's do the Michael Myers I
could watch this all day frankly maybe I
will next time
that was [__] awesome to be
honest see you next
Tuesday oh yeah true all right guys are
we all ready for me to go over there
yeah all right guys it is time are you
faster than Michael Myers the experiment
I'm going to go over to the
door is Mr Beast weird for putting his
feet up yes okay the majority are saying
yes
74% thank
you all right
[Music]
look at get a load this scary ass
dude I'm
scared all right
[Music]
yeah who's going Dan you want to go
first all right guys so we are going to
be setting up our first runner here this
is legit
terrifying
dude no
girl girl
no all right who wants to go first step
up I think Olivia should
go Zach's up come on
all
right so here's how the game works I
I'll describe it so we're going to do
this in rounds like a
tournament based on how much space you
have to run away from Mike Michael
here um and we'll get progressively
harder closer we also have gags there's
two locks we might we might do two locks
instead set of one we might do at a key
to make it harder and this is uh what
we're doing for the first round we're
doing the top lock first just the top
lock sup
[__] dude chill BR okay so where do
Zach start from start from the entrance
right here uhhuh right here all right so
there's one lock do you tell them which
one yeah top lock top lock come through
what's up all right so I'm going to come
over
here a top lock
only all
right all right so get a shot go over
there so they you can see where Jason is
or Michael or whatever whoever that
is so there's
Michael and when we say start Michael is
going to walk towards Zach and Zach
needs to get through the door
and into safety is everyone ready top
lock correct top lock you got it this is
the first round it's going to get harder
and harder all right
Zach one
two
go oh good Hustle by Zach really good
hustle okay he's in oh [__] he's oh [__]
oh okay okay all right all right he's
safe eat [__] but by the way Mike Myers
he walked through the smoke and it looks
crazy dude all right thank back back to
your
spot all right so Zach's
safe I just want to make sure it's
locked the [__] I got it there we go
geez thanks
M all right so Zach survives he is a
true competitor who will
be the Lone Survivor much like um among
usly in a sense or opposite of Among Us
Olivia how we feeling a little bit
nervous you should be look behind you I
see I thank you are you
ready one 2
go okay good Hustle by Olivia she's
trying to get that key in oh [__] it's
jammed oh god oh [__]
[__] oh yo by the way by the way by the
way Mike if there's that door's a jar
you can go through it you know what I
mean this is life or death you can't
this is life or death thank you thank
you appreciate that
sure all right ol live all right you
live
barely this first round is easy remind
you guys
it's going to get harder more
challenging more deadly or bloody or
frightening I'm
shaking okay we're all set up thank you
jigsaw Jimmy
saw oh my God my heart is racing are you
ready Sam I'm so nervous Sam is scared
my shoes are too big should I take them
off whatever you
want keep them I'll on all right Sam
look behind you feel the
3 2 1
go uh-oh she keeping the Hat
on oh wow that key made up that key went
fast oh
no she's dead she's dead oh no Sam you
died Sam the door is messed up I can't
hold on is this lock
malfunctioning let me check oh I think
Jimmy s didn't
so here's the thing someone set me
up oh you did you twist the
knob I think I twisted
the
Malik
what well anyway you you are de I wonder
if I turned it the wrong way right lock
it Dan yeah it's lock okay so let me see
double
kill so maybe you I block the top it
goes like that oh you were going the
wrong way I think maybe I was
left it turns the horror movie
sorry all right
so rest in peace thank you uh Michael
well done sir well done here I got the
key here for the
next
Sam I wish we had a taser or something
we could tase the losers to increase the
stakes here's the key thank you sir all
right next is EXC youc a true competitor
okay who wait what's going on
here holy [__] all right love I just
want to behind me okay you feeling
confident I got I got a key I got to
hurry up I all ready uhhuh 3 2 1 go okay
F he's
okay all right you love the key is in oh
oh close you got to close the door oh
[__] my [__] that house good job
house you got to close the
door house I couldn't leave the house
dude no understand it's worth a lot more
money you have a pie I I got to build
build my house dude holy [__] wow that
was close holy
[__] actually oh Z
next you better you better not touch her
dude Michael should I keep the shoes on
the taels I think it's more awesome if
you do it and they okay let's do
it oh the key pop here I
go all right wait what the [__] so which
lock is it the top one uh yes do you
have a mic uhhuh all right oh Michael
listen it's so scary you don't [__]
touch her you understand that's my night
right there slow and you mind your
business are you ready Ela
no okay okay I'm ready okay ready 3 2
one go go go go get hustle in the
boots oh God he's walking fast why you
walking so
fast hey why'd you walk so fast dude
what was that they're changing I think
they're changing what the hell heally
ran at you that kill that was the
opposite of what I asked you to do
man this is too stressful you he
was loog okay so wait I don't know I'm
confused if the lock is [__] up or not
you have to turn it to the right
okay you see when I try it I guess I
guess it's kind of like really hard okay
yeah it's not a Smooth Lock no part the
challenge wait why was he so fast did
you guys tell him to speed up he's just
hating
what the [__]
Michael everyone else he's doing like a
stroll through the park just a few
seconds Jesus
man that was not
fair are you going to yeah I'll do it
and then so Lena is up next oh Dan is
next he's in that Queen jumpsuit baby
he's looking good stret you're killing
me all right Dan you ready you Nimble
I'm ready agile okay here we go so just
go on one so three two one all right Dan
is sprinting Man Dan is fast oh he's
jiggly he can't get it in the hole he
can't get close
close whoa that was close Dan you you
survived wow that was so close
terrifying truly terrifying times here
on this Halloween day wow Dan did my I
think
absolutely terrifying times here Michael
has got made this significantly more
intense for the uh competitor but uh oh
there he is
jiggling all right Lena are you ready
I'm ready I L it I got it all right
Lena I believe in you thank you this is
your worst night right it is this is a
big phobia here yes specifically Michael
Myers specifically Michael
Myers okay so don't [__] up okay I'm
ready are you ready 3 2 1 go oh damn
there you go there we go don't look back
already oh she's panicking Oh
my Jesus Christ holy [__] holy [__] that
was real ter oh my God that was
[__] I did it though I did
it dude that was real terror are you
okay I'm yeah okay I'm okay I thought
you were going to die I was like she
dead smokes I kicked the camera is it is
the shot still
okay oh you're not
okay all right wow that was job Lina you
could be in
movie how
this wow wow wow well done Lena so we
only have or we have two fatalities
right Sam and
uh no
Liv yeah she lived and
Ela all right Cameron you feeling
fast on L gang this one's for low gang
run towards the door like you see a
corpse all right here we go three two
one
go here we go cam
hustle calmly the
the oh man oh Jesus he broke his cam is
made of steel the knife broke Cameron
you're a man
of what happened got jammed uh yeah it
wasn't oh this is like a tough one to
the left I turned it to the left whoops
a that's how that's how Sam died as well
I think there's hanging thank you s
you're dead who's
next oh I'll take there's food in
afterlife Cameron I promise I think
there's someone hanging right there yeah
all
right
AB I feel like we're at an advantage cuz
we really got to feel and understand I'm
so tempted to just kick it down but I
won't obviously so tempted to what kick
it
in I think you'll
die it's my
specialty all right everybody AB ready
like Sith L yeah I'm ready 3 2 one go I
wasn't ready good hustle bab oh my shaky
ass hands going
fast that could not have been closer
holy smoke what the knife is just
totally dude Michael was gunning for you
bro I think I may cheated a little bit
did I use my I think I might have used
my foot at moment I don't we'll have to
watch the footage your foot to do what
to get it open I don't know if that
worked though I don't think so
okay oh did it it never unlocked yeah it
unlocked getting a little funky you have
to that okay okay cool all right thank
you fantastic thank you
sir AB that was so close I guess am I
the only one left uh I got to go with
okay jigsaw getting jigsawed himself
Jimmy
saw terrifying terrifying okay scary
times man were you terrified yeah
scary you know just knowing if I was in
the movie I would have
died Ian are you ready I'm ready yes are
you Survivor we'll see all right 3 2 1
go oh [__] don't worry about about that
he dropped the left don't worry about
that he's in he's in he's close nice in
that was close too nice that was a clean
one that was clean here here oh dude
this is close close he's walking so much
faster yo Michael chill he's speeding up
I I noticed I I have a love oh okay all
right it's my
turn Okay so Ethan is
next also next person that Dr my love
automat
but okay I got to visualize visualize
yeah no yeah yours wasn't bad Dan Dan
owes me new love we trying to tell me
something no no okay I'll let you you
ready yeah I'm ready all right you want
to voice it over 3 2 1
Go
SpongeBob you [__] it got it's locked
I went to the right he got oh it didn't
go in all the way M your door stck
ah Mal your door sucks bro all right
it's a door thing double
kill a very Co surrender yeah wow [__] I
died
[__] so round one yeah round two let's
be honest I don't think anyone's
surviving round two at that if it's
harder than that
so how can we make it a little bit
[Music]
harder two two locks two locks that's
going to be really hard a slower walk
he's been speeding up yeah you chill
Michael what happened bro he's getting
excited dude you're getting too into the
part man we're just acting we're
just not
real
[Music]
all right should we do two keys I think
we should lock them both all right let's
do two keys all right so who went first
it was Olivia right oh Zach did okay so
Zach will go first again it went in I
thought it went all the way you know
what I mean but I guess he got stuck
there oh yeah see you get
stuck this is a real this is a really
disappointment to me you know what I
mean this is really that rude awakening
frankly all right wait I need a key are
they both the same key yeah
yes wait what okay it's the
same all right so both are lock
sack [__] you dude [__] you
Michael yeah chill chill Mike chill
dude we're just having
fun all right are we ready for round two
here we go Zach you ready double locks
Right double locks 3 two one
go oh God he didn't slow down he didn't
he didn't slow down a [__] me [__] you
dude okay but for real you got to slow
down bro yeah way too fast Michael
Michael
Michael I think is he is he he's gone
he's he's gone a method actor I
guess Michael slow down bro you can do
it again that that you had no shot you
had no shot I'm going again another
round yeah well he ran at him I mean
slow it
down basically it's not up to Mike who
lives it's up to the the runner you know
wait can you make sure the door is
locked though both are locked okay all
right Mike walk out like like a we'll
just walk at a normal Pace okay all
right cool all right 3 2 1
go there you go he's he's he's doing
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a great Pace
he's right behind you dude he's right
behind
you that was a good Pace well done well
done [__] you Michael that was a slow
leisurely Pace sorry Zach sorry you
tried you didn't get the top one huh
dude I'm [__] [__]
up well you win some you lose
some I lost my life yeah you're dead you
lost it all whatever I'll get over
[Applause]
it all right Olivia is going to do her
second attempt here who will be the
Survivor both locks Michael Michael
virgin has learned to walk at
appropriate
speed it's scary though when when
running from him and knowing he's coming
up on
you it's freaking dude okay all right uh
here we go three
two one go R run get H don't look back
sorry don't look back I he's coming he's
coming I
can't he coming he's coming
no oh man ruthless
absolutely
ruthless that was horrible this door is
hard I feel like it's getting harder I
swear to God it something changed I
think the more we use it the more [__]
up it
gets
yeah it's a tricky door it's a deadly
door so so far nobody has survived the
second round and this is where we Dan
here are you next
[Music]
sorry one key
open behind me or no all right they just
get stabbed all right I got to
run try to let me know what
happens we're testing it the top one is
real
tricky
all right bottom one you got to turn
left no you should cuz bottom one you
turn left okay if it's his house
presumably he knows that yeah know all
right love all right be the first
Survivor the key left
then what the turn the key left or the
the the top one is right the bottom one
is
left easy
got okay sh watch this watch this here
we go three two one
go good muscle by love he's starting
with the bottom that's a new approach he
hasn't tell
[__] wow wow we have a Survivor now that
was interesting he went bottom first I
didn't anticipate that I got
clean you are a game
no ttch all right thank you juicy thank
you sh thank you sh thank
you okay we have a Survivor you know
okay dude very excited very very excited
wow um thank you who's who do we have we
have Lena Dan
na I got I got to I got
[Music]
a thank you X I got I got it I don't
think he's going to make it I don't
think he has what it
takes but he can do no wrong at the same
time Dan is the
queen oh yeah it did fly off last time
here we don't have to use your M we can
we have our own Labs it'll be
okay what I got nice
Labs
oh all right Dan you ready I'm so ready
ready for this here we go three
two one
go good hustle dance fast he's
fast okay top lock is done it's going
the bottom one is getting Sho he look
back wow it's well done dance
survived scary though huh so scary he
looked back you know you're [__] when
you look back oh
brother do that
wow we have two
survivors this is very very interesting
I me just a few seconds exciting just a
few seconds so ab and Lena haven't gone
they are fearless ruthless competitors
especially Lena she's always the the
Dark Horse or the Black
Horse Dark Horse it's just a few seconds
all right Lena are you ready yes are you
nervous I'm ready you got this yeah
what's your strategy uh I'm just trying
not to think about it it's just a few
seconds and it'll be over which which
lock are you going to start with oh um
maybe top I don't know which one is
easier bottom start bottom I'm going to
start bottom you know bottom goes left
yeah bottom left all right all right
three two one
go go
off she here she goes she is nervous oh
god oh no oh
no oh my god oh [__] oh
no oh man your worst nightmare came to
fruition I got the bottom though I
appreciate how uh I think so I
appreciate
how how deep in the character she do
yeah are you got to go yeah all right
all right AB are will you be among the
living or will you be another corpse at
the doorstep of
Doom AB are you ready I think so three
two one go
okay okay A's off to a clean start
bottom one top one okay hold on chill
with all right that's a habit all right
AB got through oh very ni was about to
break I was I'm sorry I don't know why
it's on my first instinct kick the
[__]
thing my bad we need this thing at least
for the next you can break through it
when we're done oh hell yeah okay who's
next
tradition
[Music]
TR fun so wait is that everyone no
that's everyone no cam is
dead Ian did you let
survive okay Cam he died cam died in the
first one yeah oh all right so Ian is
the last one of round two very exciting
Stu this is a new Olympic sport I heard
coming out in the 2024 Olympic Games the
J the mik
run Ian you ready uh as ready as I'll
ever be got sneakers on kind of no lift
no support all right ready yeah 3 2 1
go good oh he's running so fast his
Hat's about to fall off oh [__] he's got
it
wow a
stunning stunning
Victory sorry not to day Michael how you
do that oh maybe not today but tomorrow
tomorrow all right so our our winners
are our survivors Ian Dan
ab and xqc wow four survivors of the
double
key all right now to make it really
[__] up oh you have an idea cuz two
keys oh you're thinking two keys
apparent Eli just said there was a
suggestion in the chat that we do it
like a horror movie like we've already
fallen over so you have to start from
the
ground that's amazing you have to
scramble up I do like that idea I do
like that idea we can do two keys too I
think two keys okay cuz I don't I don't
know if that will make a big enough
difference but I think you got to start
with two keys and they have to be in
your pocket cuz that way you can't
already be holding the correct key you
got to pull them out okay you like that
yeah okay this is going to be intense
guys all right let's set that up we're
adding another
key do you have the second key more
let's do it want me to add yeah add one
more moving on to what I believe will be
the final round who can Poss do work in
the door with two keys two logs I mean
who's going to make it through that
they're
doomed you say that I don't know Ian got
through that pretty quick that's true he
got through that real quick that's true
he did all right we're setting up the
second key right now I got I questioned
Michael Myers uh his uh loyalty to
certain people in this really you think
he's being selective oh yes oh
oh some drama I don't know I seen him
run after he ran after ELO who does
that that was mess up she's pregnant you
know
man all right so we're verifying that we
have the proper second key here that
will not open the
door seem good all right the keychain
let's show it to the camera I got to pop
this on real quick we're popping it on
go ahead we're popping pressure's on Ian
sh this is don't put it on oh wow you
guys have shaky hand solidarity together
than
Michael all right we got it right so
here is
um here is two keys look very similar so
one is for the top or no one is a fake
one one just doesn't work at all okay so
that's part of the challenge is I think
like if I if I go next I will start with
it in my pocket and I have to you can't
take it out till you're if I'm already
holding it I'll just hold on to the one
that works all right who's who's wants
to go first um I can I'm here I got the
in the pocket you can't take it out till
you're at the door till you get to the
door you get it out figure out which key
it is do it all right this one sounds
tough I don't know are you just not sure
yeah
go just not
sure all right there's going to be a lot
of D it's going to be a blood bath
placing this in my pocket pocket all
right here we go guys this is the third
and what I believe will be final round
there's going to be a lot of death a lot
of
Destruction all right here we go boys
three two one
go stand oh dude he did the Naruto
[__] run did you see how straight his
hands were like so
aerodynamic that was close so was the
key you got the key right on the first
try uh well I I looked at it first and
determined which one it was and then one
with the correct one so it definitely it
it added a moment hesitation in there so
because I don't know if they know which
key is which though I'll tell them
before yo speaking of Beast we got all
Beast bars
here I want to hit this let's have you
go
next all right xcc is coming up for his
uh Final Round Here H yeah to get a
crunch on E
stop okay so I'm going to show you love
you're going to put this in your pocket
right this one is the correct one so put
that in your pocket you can't pull it
out until you get
to all right love all right you feeling
I'm feeling
good 3 2 1
go
wait what what it's unlocked the door
was unlocked I forgot to lock it wait
was that chips fell out of your
pocket what the [__] oh no dud my G dude
you're just dropping chips that's crazy
my my gamb sorry sorry gamble that much
yeah also love you can't take the key
out till you're at the door oh
okay all right now one more
time all
right
all right here we go one more time
people three 2 one
go damn damn D what the [__] two keys
two keys two keys what the [__] D here
you go it is hard I agree
whatever you said I I'm sure I got to go
Gamba all right going to go
gamble here right
here I thought you were going to look
at
to um up next is Ian Dan is the only
Survivor so far so you know which key is
which what is this secret knowled girl
who survived this is the correct key I
told love that as well oh it's just now
put it in your pocket and you still have
to scramble to figure out you got the
right
one I'm going right pocket yeah you good
all right I think I'm ready jigsaw vers
J is the door locked this time yeah
okay let me just yeah all right 3 two
one
go he's fast you don't he's fast he's
oh God oh God oh
God wait Jason you're walking faster
again man he's being selective he's
picking saying this [__] this game
doesn't make sense Jason you got to be
consistent I think it's cuz you keep
calling him Jason or [__] Mike oh
he's like the whole game chill
dude let me reset the door all right
well I guess you're
dead dead in a bad po
situation you want to switch sure listen
Mike it's over for youbody tri this guy
you got to go been waiting all day to
find my opening to make the star war
joke you
understand do like do like this if you
understand okay thanks strong awesome
strong
all right sir all right so just a
reminder that is the correct key you got
it okay in theet
[Music]
come
hello uh ladies and gentlemen how are we
we are experiencing some technical
difficulties uh please stand by we will
get we ran out of battery we'll get
right back to your regular uh skle
program we're charging it up did they
see my my rope take off I don't I don't
yeah I don't think they saw it we're
experiencing some uh technical
difficulties blah blah blah sounding
like xqc over here thank you for joining
us on the beautiful H3 podcast it is
5:06 p.m. Pacific Standard
time are you all ready for daylight
savings next week make sure to set those
clocks God damn it thank you for tuning
in to the H3 podcast hope everyone
everyone has a beautiful Monday
evening coming up Drew Cary on The Price
is
wrong coming
up Jerry Seinfeld on chocolate can
okay we are back ladies and gentlemen so
bad Zack can you hear
me can you hear me Zach yeah he can hear
you
yeah all
right Michael be good all right I got
take my robe off
again let's do
this all right everyone ready going to
[__] come for my ass no kicking yep
no barging
TR 3 2 one
go there he goes can't at the door he's
he's really abiding by the rules oh [__]
my shaky ass oh [__] oh
[__] I'm
dead Dan
[Music]
wins wait does that mean you're the
final Survivor I'm the last girl I'm the
last
girl you live I'm the Virgin you live
let's go wow what an honor what an honor
it's been to be here today to be chased
by the Michael
Myers yeah all right oh yeah I need my
crown hold on let's go debrief let's go
debrief okay come on down
everyone you sit down okay perfect
[Music]
perfect oh no there's a cheer list I'm
the last
place me and Logan fall
Dan Dan is the queen everyone was a
fierce competitor though let's give it
out you were such a beautiful ass girl
thank you absolutely that was scary mik
how did you decide how fast to
go Michael yeah Mike what was your
theory
there don't test me oh you just
threatened you don't test me yeah okay
don't push do you have any anything else
no questions no more questions thank
you he's going to stand there ominously
behind the thank you for
the we've been doing a long episode eh
welcome uh three and a half hours baby
yeah
yes Danny's Queen
congratulations the Survivor the Virgin
the mother
Mary the Holy
Ghost like a Regal like the holy TR
Italian Greyhound
it is Dan swer love
thei oh he owns this [__] he's got his
feet up he's the
only he owns this [__]
[Music]
place that was
beautiful what was that shot of
Lena
L's I just remember chat said I could
break down the door can I please you
want to do a special round where you can
break down the door I don't want to make
everyone that long I just kind of want
to break it okay go back there with the
camera no but you got to try one run
Michael Myers let's make it you know
let's make it official you can't no key
okay just with pleasure just pure Bron
yeah okay make sure those dead bolts are
fastened guys we'll be doing the eel pit
after this so stay tuned for that super
fasinating I can't wait to see those
we'll do a deep dive on the eels you
know Dan moved really fast he's fast
yeah you know who else is faster moves
quick yeah he's
quick did I look I look I look slow
regular regular regular I I like to
think I would have gone faster but I've
got my high heel Crocs on yeah the shoes
you know mhm I you fast though oh your
microphone
oh I am fast though I'll have you guys
know they used to call
me Speedy Gonzalez in school I don't
think people use that name anymore
Speedy Gonzalez yeah isn't that the ro
oh no who's Speedy Gonzalez isn't that
like the Lun character that is no longer
did they cancel him hold on Speedy
Gonzalez yeah Luna is pretty wild for
that yeah oh no it's so racist yeah I
think that character is no no more with
us look at this [__]
Bro oh no all right so here is the bonus
round they call me Road Runner actually
okay amending my story I see here's the
bonus round AB has no keys only Brute
Force his object break through the door
Michael the pace is up to
you oh he's coming for me he's fucking's
got one God damn it and remember Michael
if the door you can go through
it [__] oh man catch 23 all right here
we go guys 3 2 1 go okay we go a is off
really strong
start you got to close the door close
the
door coming close the door barricade it
barricade it barricade
it get okay all right you did all right
well done Applause there you go I feel
like
lower what the [__] is on some [__] on
terms of his speed there well done
AB a Bonafide door breaker maybe's got a
talent for breaking doors does thank you
not
questionable sure does good thing he was
walking slow for you though cuz he could
have gone right through that
door did you tip him off AB he's walking
like so Dam I really thought he was
coming from my ass I'm out of breath did
you butter his [__] biscuits D them
no
somebody paid off Jason or
Michael stop calling him Jason should we
do should we do the eel pit or should we
save that for um um I'd love to do the
eel pit but we we're we have something
we're attending after this and it's
starting soon so unfortunately can we
stay what it is or no I mean what does
it matter we're going to a Halloween
party yeah we're all going to a
Halloween party yeah y sponsored by
Ethan and Ela thank you this is what the
third year that're putting this on and
feet binder hell yeah so Byer it's now
officially a tradition when it's three
it's a tradition we bring the teddy
fresh crew who I'm not affiliated with
by the way right nothing we do it it
will
be I get I have no interest in that
company and the wonderful people at feet
finder we want to thank they're going
sponsoring it
thaner I wish I it'd be awesome if they
paid for the
party I just got to put up right that's
a good deal but um an open an open toad
event yeah so we'll be very good you
very good thank you um so that's it I
guess we'll save the eel pit until damnn
yeah but it truly has been an eventful a
beautiful inspiring frankly evening the
most inspiring some would say the most
inspiring some say the most inspir the
most
inspir people said someone said Ethan
going out no way well I kind of have to
if it's our party his weird if I
didn't although maybe it's cool if I
don't go it's like hey guys enjoy the
party that's very El All For You the
coolest the coolest yeah it's the
coolest thank that'd be the
coolest all right guys thanks everyone
for watching I hope you had fun today
during this Halloween special happy
Halloween happy Halloween to all of you
byee have a good safe healthy time
tomorrow Lena how you what are you
planning to do tomorrow tomorrow oh my
God just working like usual I don't know
every time we C
Frozen all right guys
listen I don't we don't need cameras
anymore we just need we just Ste frames
it's fine we should do a whole show like
that where it's like just Stills kind of
artistic I would like to see that yeah
yeah okay all on guard I like that
all right have a great Halloween
everybody we'll be back on Wednesday for
another fantastic show it was Friday for
and I was like why Wednesday 82 that's
right it is not Friday all right
everyone thanks for watching see you
next time watching happy
[Music]
Halloween
he